hey guys and welcome back to a new
tutorial series so essentially this is
online game development with Python
which means we're going to be using
sockets and networking to connect what's
known as a client and a server or
multiple clients to a server where they
can send and share information and
therefore we can create an online game
so we're gonna start off with just the
absolute basics and just get shapes for
example like if I move a shape on my
computer it moves a shape on your
computer like if you're the other client
and then we'll start getting into some
more advanced stuff where we create a
legitimate game and start sending mass
amounts of information to the server and
back to the client
so we'll start really simply by just
getting everything working on our local
network and then once it's working on
our local network we'll deploy that to
an external server which will allow us
to play from anywhere in the world not
just against people on our local network
okay so what I'm showing you right now
is actually an online game that I
created with Python pi game and
networking and this is similar to
something we're gonna make obviously not
as advanced but it works on the same
principles so essentially I have what is
known as two clients now if you don't
know the way that any online game works
is we have multiple clients connecting
to one main location which is known as a
server now right here on my screen we
have two clients so this client on the
Left that my mouse is kind of going over
that has this red highlight look where
the rook is or where I just about to
move this Knight is client one and then
this black one over here so like you are
block where I just moved this pawn is
client two now you can see in the
background I have this command line
thing going and it's sending and
receiving information and this is
essentially how a online game works and
you might see whenever you guys play an
online game it says waiting for server
or connecting the server and that's
because it's doing exactly that it's
waiting to get a connection to the
server and then grab information from
that so that's the way that we're gonna
be doing things is using the client and
server now I'm not going to be using any
frameworks that are pre created like I
know there's like twisted and some other
frameworks for Python the only module
we're gonna be using that's external is
PI game and that's just to create some
very basic graphics okay so let's close
this I just want to give you as an
example of what an online game looks
like and you can see when I was moving
something on one client it would move it
on the other so let's close that up and
let's actually get started with the
tutorial no it did not mean to open that
so I'm gonna be working with
pycharm for this tutorial now if you
don't know what pycharm is it's an IDE
to download it all you have to do is
just go to the internet type PyCharm and
you can go here and click download
whatever it loads up now if you guys
don't want to use pycharm that's
absolutely fine you can do everything
using the standard editor like ideally
you can use Adam use whatever you want
but if you want to follow exactly what
the tutorial i'm gonna be using PyCharm
now the next thing we're gonna need um
other than idea I guess you don't need
PyCharm is we're gonna have to install
Pi game now for 90% of you the way that
you're going to be able to install PI
game is just by going to command prompt
loading it up like this and there's
typing pip install pygame and then
hitting Enter
now if this doesn't work for you I'll
put a card in the top right-hand corner
of the screen right now which tells you
where you can go to install PI game and
I have a video explaining you exactly
how to do this and if this command
doesn't work for you can follow that
video and I'll explain to you how to do
that so once we have PI game then we're
ready to actually start writing a bit of
code so while I launch up PI charm right
here and create a new project let me
just tell you about I don't know some of
the things we'll be going through in
this tutorial series so obviously we're
gonna be working on coding both a client
and a server and I'm gonna explain
obviously exactly how those things work
and how we can create them and then what
we're gonna be doing is we're gonna be
dealing with a bit of server like
administration if you want to say that
so actually deploying things to an
external server does stalling impending
installing dependencies working with
like a linux server to deploy our game
to and that'll be at the end of the
series that we do that right now we're
just gonna be working with what's known
as localhost which means that we're just
gonna be doing it on our own network so
right now the games that we create are
only going to work on our would call it
against people that are on our Wi-Fi or
on the same network as us and then later
it'll work against anyone in the world
that has that client downloaded ok so
let's just create a new project here my
new project I'm just gonna say is
tutorial oh it's a network tutorial
Warner's name and just as a what he
caught here just letting you guys know I
did actually mess up my thumb a little
bit it's kind of swollen so if my typing
is not the best that is actually my
excuse for that so now that I've got a
new project open I'm just gonna create a
new Python file just call this tutorial
one actually let's call this client okay
and just save that as okay cuz that's
all we're gonna be coding in this video
is just a very basic client okay so now
we've got client so what I'm gonna start
off by doing is creating a configuration
for my client and keep in mind if you
guys are using something else you don't
have to worry about what I'm doing with
this PyCharm specifics this is just the
way you have to set up a project in
PyCharm so I'm just going to sit a
client I'm going to go
to script path now we're game clients
okay
apply okay now quick sidenote all the
code that I'm about to write is
available on my website tech with Tim
net usually I have as well as that a
text-based tutorial version I'm not sure
if I'm gonna be able to write the
text-based tutorial wow this first
tutorial is out but you will see it on
there at some point import tutorial
import plugin
but yeah all the code will be available
on there in case you guys missed
something or something's not working so
we're going to start by importing pygame
and make sure that that's working once
that's working we're gonna create a
window so to do that we'll just say when
equals PI game dot display dot update
all right what am I saying PI game def
display dot set underscore caps set
underscore mode Wow
bit tired today guys and then in here
which can type width and height and then
we're gonna create these variables so
say width equals 500 height equals 500
okay so there we go
with height win and now we're just gonna
set up a few global variables so we're
gonna have to use after we care to
caption so just say hug him but display
dot set underscore caption and then here
we'll just go to caption let's just say
reliance okay alright so now let's set
up a global variable that we're gonna
use and what we're gonna do for this
global variable is it's gonna hold be
current like clients we're gonna say
that client number and we'll just start
by making that zero but we're gonna
increment that based on like once we
connect to the server which we'll do
later okay so now that we've done that
there's a few basic things this is we
always do for like a PI game project or
whatnot
I'm just gonna define redraw window okay
and in here all we're gonna do is just
PI game dot display dot update like
that's and we'll also fill the display
before we do that oops didn't mean to do
that with win dot fill and it will just
pick a color in this case I want to do
whites which is 255 255 255 okay now
yeah I just realized this is actually
gonna be a lot harder to type that I
thought because my thumb's so just
excuse me guys if I'm making a few
mistakes here okay so we got our redraw
window
and what we can do next is we can code
our main loop so I'm gonna say define
main and then here I'm just gonna create
a game loop and this is gonna run
continuously Wow our program is going
and just gonna be what's checking for
collision checking for events can
constantly asking the server for
information and you guys will see how
this works in later videos but more so
we're gonna say run equals true and you
here will say well run and it'll just
set up some very basic things that we
always do for PI games so for event in
high game dot event dog gets okay and
then all we're gonna do say if event dot
type equals equals PI game dot quit with
all capitals then we'll simply do PI
game dot quit like that don't get a
semicolon I guess we can say run equals
false as well okay for events that looks
good and then what else we'll do in here
is we'll just call that redraw window
function so redraw window like that now
what I'm thinking we should do next is
probably set up a class for our
character okay now our character is
going to be just the only object we're
working with right now and it's just
gonna represent like a rectangle that
moves like left out up right around our
screen and I guess we'll do that all in
this video moving that character around
and that will connect it to the server
the next one so let's create a class and
we'll do that up here and we'll say
class player like that
okay so we'll give it an it function if
you guys don't know much of an
object-oriented program and programming
and you want to learn I do have a
tutorial series on my channel that I
would recommend you go through if you
don't understand a lot of the stuff that
I'm doing right now okay so X Y width
Heights will be what we get in here and
this is just gonna represent actually
let's give it a color as well because
that'll be good to have X Y width height
color and yeah this will just represent
kind of our player and what variables
they're gonna have so we'll pass these
values in when we create an eclair so
self-thought y equals y this is very
straightforward self dealt with equals
width and self taught height equals
height and finally self that color
equals color so these are just our
initialization here this is what we're
going to use when we're drawing the
character when we're checking for
or stuff like that and what I'm also
gonna do to save us a bit of time in the
future I'm gonna say self dot rect
equals and then in here let's do this
okay so X Y width height like that okay
and this will just make it a bit faster
when we're trying to draw a character so
the next thing we're going to need is to
find draw now in the draw method here
we're gonna take a window so we'll call
that wind and all we're gonna do is just
draw a rectangle that represents our
character onto the screen and it'll
obviously be the appropriate color so to
do that all we have to do is just say
win dot oh no we don't do that we have
to PI game dot draw dot rack standing
for rectangle we have to first give the
window so we'll give when we need the
color so to do self dot color and then
we need a rect which will be self
thought wrecked okay and that's actually
all we need to do to draw the rectangle
to the screen now we need one more
method we're gonna use in the Skippy
Club move and move actually I believe
yeah we don't need to do anything else
in there right now as they are you mad
sorry so for move what this is gonna do
is it's essentially just gonna check
what do you call it if they press like
left key right key what not how can we
move them around the screen so the way
that we can do this really basically
essentially is just by game dot what do
you call it duckies dog get underscore
rest I believe that's it it might be key
mmm might be keys we'll see let's see if
which one works so this is essentially
gonna give us a list of all of the keys
actually a dictionary of all the keys
and essentially each key is gonna have a
value of either 0 or 1 now if one is
true that means we're currently pressing
the key if 0 is there that it means
we're not pressing the key so the way
that this is useful as opposed to doing
what we could sometimes do which is just
check for events in here is if you're
pressing more than one key at once it'll
allow you to move like diagonally or
whatnot okay so what we can do in here
now is we can just check if certain keys
are pressed and then change the x and y
values accordingly so we'll say if what
do you call it oh I guess we should
probably put this in a variable list
looks like keys equals PI game dot maybe
I feel like it's key we're gonna go
Kieffer right now puggy M key to again
so say if keys and then pygame dot k
underscore left standing for our left
arrow key and that's all we need to do
for that one and then we'll say if keys
and then pygame dot k underscore this
should this be all capitals I think it
should be
I can't underscore right and then the
next one if keys pygame dot K underscore
up and then our last one obviously is
down and then we'll change our values
accordingly inside of these if
statements so pygame dot ok underscore
down okay
so left right up down so if we press the
left arrow key obviously what we have to
do is subtract from our x value so to do
that we'll just say self that X minus
equals self dot Val now Val is something
we need to define so let's it do that up
here self dot Val equals and let's do a
value of like three for right now okay
so if we're going right we need to add
to our X so we'll do this very similar
so self dot X plus plus equals self dot
Val okay if I could type that correctly
and then to go up we're gonna subtract
from our y-values so self dot Y minus
equals self thought bail and to go down
with yourself about Y plus equals self
though now and that's the way the
coordinate system works in PI game our
coordinates actually at the top left
hand of our player where our screen so
if we want to go down we have to add to
it and then left and right is the same
in terms of subtracting and adding okay
so that should successfully move our
player we could add like a jump and
stuff in here as another time but for
right now that's all we need
I'm trying to think of anything else
that we could do right now we should
probably create a player object and draw
that to the screen just to make sure
everything's working so to do that let's
create a player should we do it up here
let's do it right above our main loop
here okay so we're gonna say brush it
we'll do it inside the main loop this
works better
we'll say P stand for player just equals
player and then we'll give it some
values need X Y width height colors so
for X Y we'll just start them out like
50/50 and then for our width let's just
do a hundred by 100 so he's nice and big
and we can see them and then we'll do a
color of green
so that would be red green blue like
that so 255 for green and then what
we're gonna do do actually is we're
gonna type in here insert in redraw
window we're just gonna pass P to our
redraw window so that we can draw him
and before we do that we'll call P dot
move and what this will do is move our
character based on what keys were
pressing so an inside redraw window
let's add a player witty code argument
attribute whatever you want to call that
start parameter that's the correct name
and then we'll just say player dot draw
like that and we'll pass win in here
which probably should be passed in here
as well because we do use wind quite a
bit so let's do P let's do win and then
P okay so let's run this now and see if
I made any mistakes I likely did process
finished oh we not never calling the
main function so let's call this main
function from down here so we're
actually executing that code that we
wrote and there we go so now we have a
little green square and you can see hmm
interesting it's not working for me to
move this around so let's check this one
more time pede move what is move doing
get pressed let's just add I want to add
something here and make sure this is
working so let's go we're gonna say
clock equals PI game dot time dot clock
okay and then in here which gonna do
clock dot tick and we'll do 60 FPS I
just want to see if this is working if
not I dunno how to fix this okay so
we're not able to actually move this oh
I know why so very interesting
we are not updating this Rex but we are
updating what do you call it like up
down left right so at the bottom here
all we're gonna do is just redefine our
erect by doing self dot X self dot Y
self thought width and self dot height
now I'll really quickly explain why this
error was happening essentially we're
defining rect up here based on the input
parameters when we're creating our
player so that means we're always just
constantly drawing our rectangle in the
same position because we're never up
this rect variable we're only updating
like X Y width height right so we just
have to redefine our rect variable every
single time that we're moving which is
fun and we can do that
so now let's see and we can move our
green square around the screen I
actually quite like the speed this
movement so yeah so essentially in the
next video what we're gonna be doing is
I'm wrapping it up here is we'll add a
little bit more to this client and then
we'll start working with sockets so we
can connect this up to a server and
we'll start talking about all the
networking aspect then
so in this tutorial we're going to be
working on coding the server and that in
the next video we're going to be
connecting this client that we made in
the last one to that server and then
sending information to and from the
server so let's get started and let's
create a new file that is gonna be our
server file so I'll just call this one
server GUI and then in here we're just
gonna have to import a few things and
I'll talk about exactly what they're
gonna do for us once we start using them
so let's start by importing sockets our
socket then we can import underscore
thread and we'll also import OS ok so
actually not OS or sys that's all we
need for that so what we're going to be
doing like I've talked about is we're
going to be using sockets and threading
to handle connections to our server and
essentially what that means is we're
gonna set up a socket and it's gonna
allow for connections to come in to our
server on a certain port so we're going
to start by just defining server which
is gonna be a string and port which is
gonna be a number now for port you guys
probably know what ports are you might
have heard them before for example like
a common port you would use on or a
common port that is used like on your
router would be port 80 and that is for
HTTP connections there's also a port
like 443 there's there's tons of other
ports that have distinct uses but
there's also a ton of ports that don't
have any uses and that are just left
open for programs like this or for
different things to be used for so what
port I'm gonna use which is typically
open it depends on like what route are
using and your internet connection but
typically a port that's open is five
five five five so we're gonna use this
port to connect to and from and it's
just a safe port to use as opposed to
trying to use another number that we
might not know if it's being used for
something else or not okay so once we've
done that we've created a server and
create a port what we're gonna do is
we're gonna set up what's known as a
socket okay and we'll talk about exactly
how this works in a second but we're
just gonna say s equals socket dot
socket and then here we're gonna type
something that's probably gonna mean
nothing to you but I'll talk about what
I mean so it's
socket equals AF underscore eye net okay
and then socket dot sock stream like
that all right now these are just the
types of connection so since we're going
to be connecting to a I P v4 address
which again we're gonna keep talking
about all this stuff as we go through in
case you guys are unfamiliar with
networks this is the type are gonna have
to use and sock stream just I believe
represents like how this server string
comes in I could be wrong on that but
this is the type we're gonna use and for
any kind of applications like this this
will be what you use for your socket
okay so we're just initializing that and
now the next thing to do is to bind our
sir and our port to the socket so to do
this we need to do a try and accept and
the reason we do this is because like I
talked about we don't know if this is
actually gonna work initially doing it
there could be in some instance this
port is already being used for something
and if that's happening that means that
this is gonna fail so we need to try and
accept this so it will accept what do
you call it error as e so let me say
socket dodged error as E and we'll just
print that out to the screen just so we
know why we're not working there
otherwise what we'll do is we'll say s
stop bind and then here we're gonna put
server comma ports okay so will bind to
whatever IP address we'll put in here to
this Gibbon port okay so I hope
everything's making sense so far
essentially what we're doing when we do
sockets is we're setting up a connection
or we're using a port on our server on
our network it's gonna look for certain
connections and then we'll be doing this
on the client side as well will be
binding or not enough of you binding
will just be connecting to a certain
server and a port and then since we're
connecting to that this server script
that we're gonna have running will see
that connection and handle it in some
way okay so now that we've done that I'm
trying to think what else we have to do
okay so what we're gonna start by doing
is we're gonna start listening for
connections so we're gonna do s don't
listen now s don't listen essentially
just opens up the port so now we can
start connecting to it and having
multiple clients connecting and whatnot
so in here this actually takes one
argument now it's optional and if you
leave it blank
means it'll allow for unlimited
connections to happen now depending on
what kind of program you're writing is
what you're gonna do for this now for me
I only want two people to be able to
connect to my what do you call it
yeah to my server so we're just gonna do
s dot listen to now this might actually
be one cuz it might be like zero one but
I think - maybe the correct thing so the
rest I'll listen for now and then we're
gonna do is we're gonna print after we
listen I will just say waiting for
connection and we'll say server started
or something like that because once we
get to this point we are running the
server and everything actually is
working like we're listening for
connection we're ready to go okay so the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to define something known as a
threaded function okay and we'll I'll
talk about again what this means but
let's just do threaded threaded
underscore client for now and I'm just
putting you don't actually have to name
it this you can name it whatever you
want
I'm just putting threaded here just so
we know this is threaded and then it's
gonna take one argument which is just
going to be Co a 10 which stands for
connection and let's just pass in there
for right now
so the way that threading works actually
let's let's do the threading and then
I'll talk about how it works says I'll
probably make a bit more sense so let's
do a while true down here okay so once
we set up our server our port we bind it
doing here we're starting to listen
waiting for connections starting the
server then what we're gonna do is we'll
be get put into this while loop and what
this while loop will do is will
continuously look for connections okay
because right here we're just listening
like once right to see if anything's on
that server report but down here we want
to continually try to grab connection
that see if somebody connected and if it
does then we want to print something to
the screen or we want to send
information or we want to start a new
thread which we'll talk about in a
second so in here what we're gonna do is
gonna say connection which Co n N and
then ad R equals and then s dot and then
we'll say accept and what s not accept
is gonna do is it's going to will accept
any incoming connections and then it's
going to store the connection and the
address and the connection is by the way
an object representing like what's
connected the address is going to be an
IP address in the
variables okay so if we get a connection
what we'll do is we'll say print
connected to okay and then a TR and this
is just gonna show us what IP address is
actually connecting so we can have a
look at that and then what we're gonna
do is we're gonna do start underscore
new underscore thread and then in here
we're going to do what was that name of
the function that we had was threaded
clients okay and I believe we do comma
and then in brackets here we do Co n
like that okay so start new thread is
there a reason that's not working give
me a sec guys I want to see why oh
that's why so up here instead of saying
import thread we're gonna say from
underscore thread import star okay and
not just gonna make it so we can just do
this start a new thread thing and you
know what I don't know if we're gonna
need this sys but let's just leave it
there for now okay so let's talk about
what writing is gonna do so essentially
the way that you guys are used to
programs working I'm assuming unless you
have some familiarity with threading is
that I say we're in this while loop
right and we were to call the function
threaded client well before we continue
going with this while loop we would have
to wait until this function was done
running or in other words we return back
from this function some value or for
example like he does like x equals five
we would have to wait for this x equals
five to execute and then it would come
back in this while loop and keep going
now we don't want that to happen because
we're gonna be having multiple
connections going at once
so what we want to do is we want to
start at what's called a thread and a
thread is just another process that's
running in the background so that just
means when we do start a new thread and
we do threaded client it's gonna run
this function but it's not gonna need
this function to finish executing before
it continues the while loop so this is
gonna be running in the background as
like process two while process one is
still running and still going so that
means say we connect to a hundred
different things we're gonna have a
hundred different functions running so a
hundred different threaded clients on
the stock or like keep going and
then what we're gonna have is this while
loop still continuing to go what did I
just do still continuing to run to look
for another possible connection you guys
will see more how this works but
essentially just means this will run in
the background and we don't have to wait
for it to finish executing before we can
accept another connection not that's the
basic kind of wait that works so now
let's start working with threaded client
and then we will test the server out and
see if it's working and then obviously
in the next video we're going to connect
to it and do all the connection stuff
okay so in here threaded client so what
should happen when we connect to a
client well we're gonna have to do a
while loop in here
sorry I said Wow true because we want
this to continually run while our client
is still connected okay now what we're
also gonna do is we're just gonna say
reply equals blank like that and much
copying from my other screen because
this one is a bit finicky I don't mess
it up we're gonna put a try in here and
we're gonna say is we're going to try to
receive some kind of data from our
connection okay from whoever's connected
we want to receive some kind of data so
what we'll do is we'll say I believe
it's s con dot receive that might be
right yeah I think that's right and then
here we're gonna put the amount of bits
okay now if you guys know anything about
computing you know like how what bits
represents but essentially this is the
amount of information we're trying to
receive now if you're getting an error
when say you'd like do this and you
connect up and you get some area that
says woody call it like object was true
on store like you're getting any errors
just increase this size okay and you can
just do that by like putting this like
times eight or something just note that
the larger this size is the longer it's
gonna take to receive information and
that's obviously because the more
information you're getting the longer it
takes to send that over the server so
2048 bits is not a lot it doesn't take
very long it happens almost instantly
but if you bump this number up to a ton
then it will take longer to do that okay
so data I'm going to say reply equals
and I'm going to say data dot I think
it's actually string D
hmmm let's see this Oh da da da decode
cuz it'll be in that bad object that
Dada decode and then here we gonna do u
TF comma 8 now the reason we have to do
this is because whenever we're sending
information over a like client-server
system we have to encode the information
and you'll see that in the next step
that we're gonna encode information
before we send it back to the client but
that means that we're receiving encoded
information so to actually be able to
read it like a human readable string we
need to decode it first so it's really
easy to do that we just do decode and
we're just giving the format which is
utf-8
okay so reply equals that and then we're
gonna say it's gonna say if not data
we're going to print disconnected okay
and then we're gonna break and this just
means if we try to get some information
from the what decode the client but
we're not getting anything we're gonna
disconnect and we're gonna break and
that likely means that we will
disconnected from the client or the
clients left or something like that so
instead of continuing to run this while
we've been trying to get information
from a client that's disconnected we're
gonna break this is just kind of a
fail-safe to make sure you don't get
into any infinite loops and it's also
gonna show us if we're running into any
issues with like receiving the data and
decoding it which we'll talk about later
okay so otherwise so if we are getting
information all we're gonna do is we're
going to print received is that how you
spell received maybe and then we're
gonna put what do you call it rip fly
okay I didn't mean to do that
let me see if I'm spelling this right I
have known to get received reply so this
just means we received from the client
this reply let's print it to the screen
and see what it looks like and then
we're gonna print sending : and will
this printer fly okay and then we'll
talk about this again in a second why
does this keep happening okay reply next
now after this if not data break out
what we'll do down here is when we say
con dot send all and we're going to send
STR dot encode
reply now again remember that since
we're sending information over the
server we have to encode our information
so all this is gonna do is just encode
our string reply into a bytes object so
that means when we read it in from the
client side again we'll have to decode
that information it's kind of annoying
but I mean it's a security thing right
so now we're just gonna accept I guess
what it what kind of error would it even
be I don't even know if there's gonna be
any errors if we run into anything let's
just break just to make sure that we're
not you know getting in that infinite
loop or we're not gonna ruin the program
by doing that okay so this is actually
about it for our server let's see how
much time we're out 13 minutes okay so
now what we need to do is figure out
what this server number is and then we
can actually test it and see if this is
working so what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna find this server number not
to do this we're gonna be doing this
over localhost okay that means that arc
we're only gonna be able to connect over
our local network meaning that like
anything on our Wi-Fi network that can
see each other that'll work fine but as
soon as for you outside that network it
won't work so we're gonna be using
what's known as local IP addresses so to
find the local IP address of the machine
you're currently on you're gonna go to
command prompt in the bottom left and
then you're just gonna type IP config
okay now some of you guys are probably
freaking out because you can see my IP
address right now this is a local IP
address and that means that it is
locally assigned to my network no one
outside of my network can see this IP
address or companion or cândido us it or
anything like that okay so it's
perfectly fine if you guys see this
address or if other people know what
this local address is good just as a
note so we're gonna do is we're gonna
take this ipv4 address so I'll just copy
that and we're gonna paste that inside
of the string here okay so 10 to 11.2
5207 is mine now yours likely is like
192.168.1 like a massive network usually
they use 10.10 like as the default
gateway which is what they're using
so my IP address star to the 10 yours
likely starts with 192.168.1 or dot like
five or something like that and then the
rest of it okay so that's the address
we're going to use and this is going to
be our server
address so whatever machine that you're
gonna be running the server script on
that's the address you want so say you
want to run this server on your laptop
and you want to run clients on like your
PC and your Mac or something like that
then you want to make sure you get the
IP address from your laptop and you're
putting it in that script okay and we'll
talk about more of this in the next
video and we actually connect to it okay
so now that we've done this I probably
made a mistake but let's actually just
create a configuration quickly for
server and run this and just see if
we're getting any errors as of now now
it is worth noting that we're not gonna
be able to connect anything yet so
there's not really gonna be much we can
see or really do but for now let's just
test this out so let's have server let's
run this and you can sees waiting for a
connection service started so it's
actually good if you're getting this
string of text everything is currently
working in the next video we'll probably
have to debug a little bit once we start
connecting to this but for now that is
the main server script now I'll briefly
just talk about before I end this video
how it's gonna work in terms of running
the server script and running the client
script the server script always has to
be running okay so whatever you're
trying to connect you have to have first
run the server script and then you can
run multiple client scripts from
wherever on the network you want now the
server script has to be running on the
machine that the IP address is like this
little string here okay it has to be
running on that machine and you can run
a client script on the same machine that
the server scripts running and you can
run multiple client scripts on the same
machine so like for example what I'm
gonna do to test this in the next video
is I'm gonna run the server and then I'm
gonna run to clients on this machine and
we'll see that it like is moving back
and forth for them
so what we're gonna be doing in this
video is we're gonna be coding the kind
of client side of this so connecting to
the server I know we already coded a
client but we're gonna code like the
network aspect of the client so that it
can connect to the server it's not as
much code it's a bit more
straightforward and then we're just
gonna test out sending very basic
information to the server and hopefully
getting some back see if that's working
okay and then in the next video we're
gonna be connecting this so like the
little user interface we created with
moving that block around in the first
video we're gonna be connecting that so
that we can have multiple clients
running and we can see like different
blocks moving on each screen okay so
that will involve a bit more work
hopefully by video 5 we'll have like a
fully working kind of game that's
working over the network okay that's the
goal so within this video I just want to
start by saying on this server class
here or sorry server file I did actually
forget two lines of code in the last
video so after this except break in
threaded client just need to add this
print lost connection and then
connection dot close all this is doing
is once we break out of this threaded
client we're just letting the we're just
gonna print this to the console so we
can see what it looks like and then
we're gonna close that connection so
that we can possibly reopen it in the
future okay really straightforward
that's all you gotta add so just make
sure you add that before moving on okay
so next we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a new file and I'm gonna call
this network okay now you don't have to
put what I'm going to in a new file it's
just a lot easier so that's why I'm
gonna do that so soon network and in
here we're gonna import socket now what
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna code a
class it's gonna be responsible for
connecting to our server this just makes
it like so I can reuse this class in the
future and you guys could reuse this
class in the future and it's just a bit
cleaner and nicer and this way I like to
do things so I'm gonna say class network
again call us whatever you want and in
here we're just gonna set an
initialization function will take
actually as Network do we need anything
in network no I think we'll just leave
like that so we're gonna say self dot
clients equals socket dog socket it's
gonna be the exact same arguments as
last time so it's a socket dot if' net I
think is that what it is AF underscore
net AF underscore inet okay and then
we'll do
socket dot sock stream like that okay
now we're gonna define the server and
the port again so self dot server equals
self thought port equals five five five
five now for the server this again this
number has to be the same as the one you
used in the server what do you call the
server file here so no matter what like
no matter where you actually are like
what client you're using this number is
gonna stay the same because this is the
server you're connecting to it's not the
clients address we don't actually have
to define the clients address anywhere
it'll automatically get that for us okay
so what we're gonna do now we have
clients server port we need to do this
so I thought addr equals and then we're
gonna say server so self thought server
and that self dot port in here okay and
then self dot way decode self thought ID
is gonna be equal to self dot connect
okay now you guys actually let's just do
self duck connects right now and we'll
talk about why I was gonna add this ID
later once we add that functionality the
server again essentially I wanted to
have an ID that was returned here alike
that was stored in this network object
just because we are gonna have to like
be sending an ID to each of our clients
so they know if they're like player one
or player too but we'll do that later
because we don't really we can't really
do that yet
okay so we've called this connect method
so we need to write that now so let's
say define connect okay and in here I
believe we should probably be given
actually like it's probably fun just use
self right now what we can do is we can
say self dot clients dot connect okay
and then if you renew self dot addr now
we're gonna throw this in a try
and except just in case you know this
isn't working so we say try so accept
and it's a renew socket error let's say
accept and we'll just pass right there
okay just in case this doesn't work
so we'll try this we'll try to connect
accept pass now once we actually connect
what we're gonna do is we'll return
I'm just looking out the screen right
now self-taught client receive and then
we'll do 2048 dot decode okay so what
this is gonna do I'll talk about this
because it might be a little bit
confusing is when we connect we want to
actually send some kind of information
immediately back to the object that
connected to us so like for example it's
going to I didn't mean to close that
what's going to server here and you can
see when we initially connect we're not
sending any information until we receive
something now that's fine but when we
connect we should really send some kind
of like validation token or like ID back
to our network object or back to our
client so what I'm gonna do in here that
looks like calling dot send okay and
then in here what we're gonna type is
let's see what should we really type
here uhm STR dot in code then here we'll
say connect it like that okay just so we
know that we did indeed connect so that
means if we set this equal to a value so
self thought I don't know let's say ID
equals self dot connect
what'll happen is when we connect will
return that string connected so this
will get connected and since it's
encoded we need to decode it obviously
so if we want to print actually in here
self got ID
it should say like connected ok let's
see if that works ok so now that we
actually have that let's see if we can
connect to the server and then we'll
deal with sending information from the
client to the server as opposed to just
getting it from the server ok I know
it's a bit confusing right now
understand figure out the best way to do
this so let's try this guy so we're
gonna say N equals Network oldest type
is at the bottom of the script we won't
do this after will delete this just for
testing purposes and then we're just
gonna say actually that's probably all
we need to do because it'll just print
our ID
ok so let's create a configuration for a
network so new configuration type
network in here and then select that
path and then let's test if this is
working so remember what I said when
we're gonna connect right to our server
what we have to do is first run that
server script so let's run the server
script here waiting for connection
server started ok let's run this network
script now invalid argument was supplied
s don't listen to hmm ok so I had a
quick look here I realized the mistake
was I was actually running this server
two times so obviously that's not gonna
work for us so we can put two back in
this listen I'm not sure if you guys
will see if I left that in the video or
not but let's go to network and we also
need to change this to AF instead of I F
I don't know why I typed I F I've
literally set AF when I was typing it
but that's fine and we have server I'm
actually running it right now so make
sure you guys run that and then let's
run that we can see if this works
ok sweet so I know it doesn't seem like
much but you can check here if we go to
server it says connected to and then
gives us that address is also printing
out some other thing that I honestly
don't know what that means and then
saying disconnected and lost connection
sweet that's actually really good and
that means that where everything is
working and you can also see that we
have connected being printed here so
that means when we connect to the server
we're actually getting the value that is
sending so we're getting this connected
and we're printing it out decoding it
all fine so that's really awesome so now
the only next step is to actually send
information to the server and keep like
a loop going like sending receiving
sending receiving sending receiving now
let's actually just test if I run this
again you can see again obviously it's
working again so this is the server just
continually is running I don't actually
have to stop this unless I want to make
modifications to it so let's just keep
that running for now and let's add
something to our network class so in our
network class we're going to define a
method that's gonna be sent now this
method is gonna be very useful later on
because it's gonna save us a lot of time
so in Santa bridge can't take a string
which is gonna be data ok and all we're
gonna do in here is we're going to try
to self dot client dot send and we say
data STR actually dot income
Donna and then we're gonna get a reply
from that service we're gonna say return
so exact same thing that we're doing
here self-thought client I receive 20
48.2 code and will accept and I believe
this is a socket error yeah the socket
cut error as eat and just print e so if
we get into some error we're you know
either we're sending or we're receiving
it's not working let's just print that
Arab to the screen so we have a look at
what that really means so now let's do
test and try to send information to the
server and then get something back okay
now the information that we're getting
back should just be the same information
because that's what we have in server
we're just gonna send exactly what we
got right back right so doesn't make
sense right now to do that but we'll
talk about like what we can what valid
information we can send how to send
receive information in the next video
when we connect up the client to the
thing okay so what we're gonna do is
gonna say and not send and we'll print
and not send okay and we'll print and
not send again and let's just send like
a few bits of information and see if
everything is indeed working ok so n dot
send and then in here you let's just
type hello and we'll type working okay
and see if this works so we have
actually we should have yeah server is
working well let's run our client and
you can see we get connected
hello working and if we come here it
says received hello sending hello
received working sending working so
that's awesome that means our network
class is working sending information
receiving information is working server
is working and now the only thing that's
left to do essentially is to connect
that up to this so use this network
class and some meaningful way here and
then to actually store information on
the server and then send that
information to multiple clients which
we'll doing in future videos
what we're gonna be doing is we're gonna
be hooking up our graphical client to
our server so that we can send
information back and forth and ideally
at the end of this video what we're
gonna have is we're gonna have two
rectangles on each client so I like two
clients running and when you move the
rectangle on one client it moves on the
other and vice versa okay so you guys
will get the idea when we go through but
there's a little bit of work we have to
do and we're going to be modifying a few
things within a lot of the files you've
already created so just make sure you
guys are paying attention and again if
anything is going wrong feel free to
download all the code off of tech with
Tim net it'll be available there and
it'll be exactly the same code that I'm
writing right now okay so first thing
we're gonna do is in this network class
we're just gonna delete a few things so
this testing stuff we don't need anymore
this print statement for the self that
ID we don't need that and we're actually
gonna change this self dot ID to be self
thought pause okay and you guys will see
why we're doing that in a second and
we're gonna add one quick method in here
and it would you guys say define gets
pause okay and all we're gonna do here
is just return self thought pause
alright and again we'll you'll see why
we're doing that but I don't have to
come back to this Network class so we'll
do that right now okay so from inside
our client now what we're going to do is
we're going to import this Network class
because we're gonna use it in here so
we're gonna say from network import
network and then in our main function
down here what we're gonna do is
actually above player we're gonna say
and equals Network okay like that and
then what we're gonna do is we're going
to say start pause equals n dot get
pause so essentially why I'm doing this
is because when we first connect to our
server what I want to happen is I want
it to return to each of our clients the
starting position of their character
right or of their cube okay because it's
going to depend where they're starting
based on if their player one or if their
player two so that on the client side
what we're gonna do is when we initially
connect to the server which is what
we're doing when we create this network
object we're connecting to the server
we're gonna get that starting position
and then for creating our own player
we're going to use that starting
position to determine
where we're starting so the position is
gonna come in as a topple all right and
we'll be coding all this on the server
side in a second but it's easier just to
go through each file rather than going
back and forth it's gonna come through
as a table whether it look something
like this so it'll be like 50 100 okay
so what we're gonna do is you're gonna
read this top line because it's actually
going to comment as a string like right
you'll see how it comes in we're gonna
get the two aspects of it's like the x
value and the y value and then we're
gonna use that inside of this player
initialization to accept the initial
position so that reminds me what we're
gonna be doing when we're sending
information to the server is we're gonna
send it using string data right and
that's what we were doing in the last
video is we were sending everything with
strings so we're sending like hello and
then we were decoding in and coding it
now this is not the only way we can send
information we can actually send
information with objects and I'm gonna
show you the advantage of doing that in
the next video but for now we're just
gonna send strings so since we're gonna
be sending strings the strings that I
want to send our positions okay I want
to from each client send the current
clients position to the server the
server is gonna get that position
update it on the server side and then
send the other clients position back to
the client you guys will see how it
works in a second actually let's see if
I can do a quick drawing to illustrate
this because they'll make things a bit
easier
okay let's I don't know why I had this
let's delete that okay so let's do a
quick drawing so we're gonna have is
gonna have client 1 and excuse me some
drawing this with the mouse and client -
I guess that's gonna be one and this is
gonna be - all right this will do it as
a red box is going to be our server and
on the server what we're gonna do is
we're gonna store positioned so select
one has position like one - okay sorry
this is harder than most guys and then
client - we'll have position like three
and one okay so it's gonna store these
positions so what's gonna happen is when
we initially connect client one is going
to go to the server it's gonna connect
to it and then it's gonna be sent back
the starting position for the client
okay so it's gonna be said okay so you
client 1 so that means you're gonna
start at position 1 - client - it's
gonna connect it's gonna say ok we're
client - so I need to send client two's
position so let's send that back
all right now let's say we've already
connected quiet ones their clients twos
there and we've set their starting
positions what we're gonna do next is
now we're gonna continually call to the
client and update the position so what
we're gonna do is say let's say we're
working with client one okay what it's
gonna do is it's gonna send its position
to the server so it's gonna say let's
just say pause okay it's sending its
current position let's say that position
is like four oh five sorry this is
really hard with the mouse okay four or
five what's gonna happen here is we're
gonna say okay so you're updating your
position so then it's gonna go in here
it's gonna say okay client one will
update your position to be four five
like that okay and then what it's gonna
do is instead of sending back this same
position because we already know what
the position is it's gonna send back the
position of client - so it's gonna send
three one and then on here we can draw
that client so that it looks like it's
moving right so we're getting we're
sending our information and then in
return we're receiving the other clients
information now the same thing we're
exhale with client two so if client two
connects right and it's sending
information it's gonna send its position
let's say it sends the position one
three okay that's its updated position
so this is going to change to be one and
three and then what's gonna happen is
it's gonna say okay well we don't need
clients twos position we need clients
one
sowhat's client one position well that
is four or five so let's send four or
five over to client two and then on
client two we can draw four or five so
you'll see they'll simultaneously be
moving I hope that makes sense I just
want to draw it out peace you guys know
what I'm about to do in this video okay
perfect now the only thing is we need to
send these positions as strings so we're
actually gonna have to implement two
helper methods so that we can convert
those positions which are gonna be
tuples in districts and then we can also
read the string into a tuple so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna say define
and I want to remember what I call this
one we'll say this one is read
underscore position which means we're
gonna take a string value and we're just
going to read the string in so we'll say
STR equals Str don't split and we'll
split it at a comma okay and you guys
will see how this works in a second and
then we're gonna do is we're simply
gonna return
int of string zero so STR zero okay
comma int STR one so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take a string in that
looks something like this if you have 45
comma 67 okay
in in string value 45 67 we're gonna
split it which means we're going to get
a list that has the string 45 in the
string 67 and then we're just going to
convert those to int and return them as
a topple so now we get that convert it
to something that looks like this which
is useful information that we can
actually use okay so that's what read
pause is going to do but we need to make
one more which is going to convert that
position into a string so we're going to
say make underscore position and in here
what we're gonna have is we're gonna
take a topple so let's say top standing
for topple and what we'll do here is
we'll say let's see here
return top actually STR of top zero and
then we're gonna add that comma in so
sorry I'm butchering my typing right now
comma plus STR of top one and I hope
that makes sense how we do that so
that's returning the string value so
we're reading pause and making pause and
that's all we need to do for those
helper functions okay so that means
though that when we get the position
initially from our server it's gonna
come in in that string value right it's
gonna look like 4567
so we need to convert that so what we'll
do is we'll say read pause let's put
that around and get pause because it's
gonna return to us that string position
so we're reading and now what we're
gonna do is for our player we're gonna
say start pause zero and start pause one
okay and what this is going to do is
just set it to the initial start
position we're going to code all the
server stuff after it'll start making a
lot more sense okay now what we also
need to do is we need to create a second
player because we're gonna have to draw
the first player and the second player
on the screen right so we're gonna say
p2 equals and we're literally just gonna
copy this except for start position
we're just gonna put it as 0 zero for
right now and we'll update that in a
second okay so we have p p2
and for now that's what we'll do
actually once we can continue working in
here so that we don't have to do
anything else in here after we'll just
code the server side so what we'll do
now is we're gonna send our current
position to the server right that's like
the algorithm we've developed
essentially we are when we connect we're
gonna get the starting position we're
gonna set that starting position and
then every time after that so like every
time the frame updates we're going to
send our position and then get the other
person so we're gonna say is we're gonna
say P to pause is gonna be equal to and
dot send
okay and we're gonna send make position
of and then we're gonna have to do in
here is it's a little sketchy but we're
gonna do P dot X P dot y now right
because that's the position of our
player the X and the y coordinate we're
putting it in tupple form we're sending
it to the function make position which
is going to turn it into a string and
then we're sending it to the server
right okay awesome so I think that makes
sense and then what we're gonna do
simply is 4p2 we're going to update is
its position so we'll say P 2 dot X is
gonna be equal to actually + 2 dot sent
but where you have to put around here
sorry is make pause read pause because
right it's coming in as a string so we
need to convert this into our actual
position so at P 2 pause is going to be
P 2 position 0 and then P 2 dot Y is
going to equal to P 2 P 2 pause 1 okay
now the only thing that's left to do
here is what do you call it draw P 2 and
update P to s rectangle so what we're
gonna do now is in the redraw window
down here we're gonna put P 2 we're
gonna go to redraw window or in say
fillet here to here and then we're gonna
do player 2 dot draw window because
again it's gonna be a player object so
that'll be fine and then last thing to
do is just update the rectangle so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to say P 2 dot
update and we're gonna go to player
object now we're just gonna add this one
function that is define update and then
so you see I just made that self dot
wrecked equals XY width height and then
in here I'm just gonna say it self
updates
like this okay so I know these might be
getting a bit confusing but we're almost
finished just gonna do the server side
and then we'll recap through everything
what we've done explain things I'd kind
of have to get this content out okay so
define update so what we're doing again
here as before we just had this line of
code here so we're just replacing that
with an update method that's pretty
straightforward I hope that makes sense
to you guys and that's just again so
when we change the X and we change the Y
value of p2 directly then we are
updating the rectangle so when we draw
it to the screen it's in the correct
position okay so I believe that's all I
have to do for the client side so now
it's time to go to the server side and
the server side is pretty
straightforward now that the server
needs to keep track V positions right it
needs a whole player once position and
players to position consistently so we
can decide if we won't destroy that
let's say like on a hard drive or if we
wanted to store that in memory now in
our case it's not a lot of information
so we're just going to store it in the
memory of the server right so what we'll
do for that is we're gonna create a list
and we're gonna say pause equals and
just a blank list and this list is gonna
hold the positions of our players now
actually that reminds me we're gonna put
two tuples in here and these are gonna
represent serrate the starting positions
of our players so we'll start with zero
zero and like a hundred a hundred so
player 1 will start at zero zero player
two will start at 100 hundred okay and
that's all we're gonna do for that
little list there and then we're gonna
do down here
well this while loop is and we're gonna
keep track of how many players have
connected in our case we only want two
to connect right and then we need to
keep track of well those players so
we're going to say is where I say
current player equals zero now this is
because when we connect we're gonna add
one to this so that when we go back into
this function it'll be you guys we'll
see how it works but essentially every
time we create a new connection so every
time this we accept a new connection
we're gonna add one to our current
player so watch we do it at the bottom
of the while loop we'll say current
player plus equals one this is just to
keep track of which player we're using
so that we know what position to update
what position to send to that player
based on the connection right okay so
keep track of current player and now
what we're gonna do is when we start
this new thread so this threaded client
where else we're gonna pass another
argument
which is going to be the current player
so instead of just passing connection
we're also gonna pass player in here
okay current player like that okay
because that's gonna be important
information to know all right so we're
actually almost finished we just gotta
update a few things
so let's actually grab these two methods
from our client class or client file and
throw them on to server here so we're
just gonna put them right above position
because we're gonna need to use them
read pause and make pause so now when we
initially connect to our player right
this is what happens when we initially
connect the first thing that sent is
this encoded message that is connected
now in our case what we want to send is
we want to send the starting position so
how do we do that well we know what
player we are we're either player 0 or
either player 1 right because we hat
when we have two players when we start
with player 0 after player 0 connects
then we do player 1 right so what we'll
do is we're going to send pause player
now that won't work because it's just a
topple right we need to first convert
that to a string and then encode that
string and send it so it should go back
here I want to keep this string dot
encode so string dot in code and we'll
say make
underscore or pause and then we'll just
put pause player in here and what
that'll do is it'll convert it into
string for us and then it will send that
to the player for us right and then
they'll read that string in compare it
to position and update the position
accordingly okay
making sense hope so okay so that's how
that works for player now the only thing
we need to change now is what
information we are sending every time
this loop is running right every time we
receive something from the player we
want to send back the other players
position so to do that what we're gonna
do is we're gonna second receive decode
so we'll get rid of this for now and now
what we're gonna say is we're gonna turn
this data into like readable a readable
Topol right so to do that we are going
to use the read position method that
we've already created or function so say
read pause Conda receive
and we'll turn that into from that
string like this right or whatever it
was like 4567 we'll turn that into
something that looks like this so that
we can actually use it okay so now that
we have that it's turned into that what
we're going to do is we're going to
update our current players positions
we're going to say pause player equals
data right because this is the position
they sent to us so what's updated on the
server so yeah so it's updated
information okay sweet so we've done
that now all that's left to do is send
the other players position back to our
client so to do that what we can do is
simply say reply equals and we're just
going to say pause or actually let's not
do it up here let's do it down here
I mean say if player equals equals one
so if we're player one we're gonna send
player 0th position right so let's say
reply equals and then Thomas player or
not pause not not player zero sorry and
then else we're gonna send so say reply
equals pause one okay so if we're player
one we send player zero position if
we're players here we send players one
position right like I was talking about
with that little algorithm we're gonna
use okay and then instead of saying
received and sending actually yeah we
can say received replies sending reply
or rulest a received data sending reply
that should work fun okay all right now
what we'll do is we're gonna send all
the reply but the thing is our reply we
need to first convert into a string so
to do that we're and say make underscore
pause write that function we've already
created and then that should actually be
about it now I'm probably made a mistake
or two here but let's just test this out
and see if everything's working so let's
start by running the server and then
let's run to clients and see if we can
connect or if there's any errors
okay so we've connected with client one
let's run client two and let's see what
happens so I'm on client one right now
you can see that when I move my green
square it moves on the other client kids
go to the other one and when you look at
this when I move it on here it moves on
the other client so we have successfully
set up and connected our two clients
together
now the only thing I want to change
quickly is just the color of these so
that we know who is whom like which
square am on so to do this we're just
simply gonna go well actually close the
survey class so though I was gonna write
it to an issue or server instance
whatever it is what a client and instead
of having the same color here we're just
gonna change this to be 255 for player
two and now I want to show you what
happens because some of you are probably
to be confused with what's about to
happen here but it's kind of interesting
so let's run server
let's run client one let's run client
two now notice that these colors are
inverted now can anyone think of why
that might be so Green right is gonna be
your current player so right now I'm on
here I'm on this where my mouse is and
I'm moving the green square that's near
the middle of the screen okay but notice
on the other screen it's moving the red
square that's because on your client
it's unique to you so on your client you
are green and red is the other person
meanwhile if I go to this client and I
start moving see green is me and red is
the other guy right and he's not
currently moving now if I wanted to move
these at the same time I would just have
to be running these on different
computers or I would have to change like
the arrow keys to move them and that's
just because obviously right like if I'm
pressing the arrow keys on here it's not
gonna work on this client but if I were
to load up my laptop and try doing it on
there this would work fine as well
there's a quite a few issues that we may
run into when we're doing this so I've
set this up essentially to be kind of
like an example program or like an
example problem to give you guys an idea
of the way we go about doing things in
terms of server and network but it's
really not ideal the way that we've
coded things so far now I did plan this
for to do what we're about to do but
essentially I'm gonna redo what we've
just done in a much more elegant and
nicer way that's going to allow for a
better scalability of this program okay
so what we're gonna do is I'm going to
redo it here I'm gonna show you how we
can actually send physical or not
physical but like send objects to the
server and from the server back to the
client rather than just string data and
then in the next videos we're actually
gonna scrap all this code that we've
written and we're gonna start from fresh
and code like a networking game there's
gonna be a lot more complex than just a
few squares moving around the screen so
that's my plan for this series let me
know what you guys think of that I know
it might be little bit frustrating to
get rid of this code but now that we
understand how a lot of this works it's
gonna be really fast to rewrite it in a
much more elegant way so what I need to
first start by doing it's just taking
this player class okay and I'm just
gonna copy it into its own file so
really straightforward I'm just go to
new Python file I'm gonna call this
player with a lowercase and then just
copy that player class in there and just
imports PI game up here okay
import PI game now I'm just gonna go
back into client we can delete this
player class now and what I'm gonna do
really basically it's just from player
import player like that okay and that's
the first step now remember I said we're
gonna send objects so that actually
means that we're not going to need this
read pause and make pause thing and it's
kind of annoying how we've had to well
take that tupple object decompose it
turn it into integers and then change
object properties and then when we want
to send something we got to put it into
a string and we got to send it in just a
pane and we don't want to have to do
that especially when we're sending tons
of different bits of information not
just that same positional data right so
we're actually going to delete this and
we can delete this client number
about there and we're gonna start just
making some modifications in terms of
sending data and receiving data so it'll
start on the client side and then we'll
go over the network the server side and
fix some of that so wherever we see that
read pause and make pause we can just
get rid of that for right now
we don't actually need any of that we're
not gonna need this p2x stuff we don't
need P 2 dot update well we'll get rid
of all this for right now you know
actually let's get rid of start position
let's get rid of P and let's get rid of
P 2 and we're gonna recode all this okay
so actually um P 2 P that can stay there
pita move is fun okay so we got rid of
all that and you can see we've just
cleaned up this file but and we'll start
working with some more stuff in a second
now what I want to do actually is go to
this network file that we have and we're
gonna start making some modifications in
here as well so what we're gonna be
doing is we're gonna be sending objects
so that means we're gonna send like an
instance of the player class and that's
actually what we're gonna be sending
instance of a player class to our server
as opposed to sending like string data
and then updating the object on or then
updating the string data on the server
then sending it back and then updating
the object that's just a lot of work
it's a lot easier just to send the
actual object so we can do that using
something called pickle okay now it's a
weird module name but it comes default
with Python and this allows us to do
something that's called serialized
objects and that just means we turn into
byte information which is like all the
zeros and ones send it over the woody
codes send it over the network and then
we can decompose that turn it back into
an object and use it it's really easy to
do that so what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna modify a few things in our
network class so first thing instead of
having self dub pause we're gonna say
self thought P okay this game equal to
self dot connect and so saying get
position will this to get P and then we
returned self dot P okay and that's all
we need to modify for that but now in
the connect in the send we're going to
change a few things as well so since
we're gonna be getting object data what
we have to do in the connect is we have
to decompose that object data so to do
that you do pickle dot loans
okay now what this stands for is a sense
for load byte data okay and we'll talk
more about this as we keep going through
but that's essentially what it means and
same thing here in send instead of
encoding this data what we're gonna do
and I guess decoding as well is we're
going to dump it into a pickle object
and then send it so to do that we're
gonna use sa pickle
at least one pickle yet don't don't
dumps like that and we'll just put data
in there okay and then when we receive
we'll do the same thing as before we'll
say pickle dot loads and then we'll load
that in so now essentially what we're
doing is we're gonna be receiving an
object decomposing that object getting
the actual object not the bytes form of
it and then we're sending it we're gonna
first like what do you call it encrypt
it like send it into that byte
information and then on the server side
will decompose that as well okay so
we'll go through that but that's all we
need for the network side so now let's
go to server and start making some
modifications so same thing here we no
longer need this read pause and make
pause functions we're not going to be
using those and we don't need this pause
list either we're gonna change this
actually to be players and it's gonna be
equal to two new players so notice that
we're gonna actually store the player
object on the server as opposed to on
the client side and this is not only
like safer because it means that the
player technically can't really mess
with the player objects they can only
like do commands to update them but it's
also just like it's gonna be a lot
easier and you guys will see how it
works we I said player and we'll do
another instance of player and in here
what we're gonna do is we're just gonna
create two new players so here's a 0-0
50 50 and we'll give it a color in this
case the first color will be red so
we'll say red green blue like that and
for the other player we'll start him out
a hundred a hundred like before we'll be
fifty fifty and then we'll make his
color blue why not so I'll do that okay
so now you notice that we're getting a
little error for player here just cuz we
forgot to import it so just say from
flare import player like that and that's
why I made this new file by the way just
so that we'd be able to see it from the
server
side and the client side as well and
then wherever we're doing this like send
encoding stuff we're gonna change this
so let's do that now actually so instead
of con dots and instead of encoding some
string information we're just going to
send the player object so what we'll do
is we'll say players like this and then
player right so exact same kind of
concept as before in that we're gonna
send the initial like starting position
of the player or like the but in this
case we're just setting the initial
player object which means any
information that's stored in that player
will be given to the client as opposed
to just the position okay so next what
we'll do is instead of saying data
equals read pause and decoding we're
gonna get rid of this dot decode and
we're gonna put pickle dot loads okay
and actually when I'm sending this
player object my bad here guys we got to
do pickle dot dumps okay and then we're
just gonna have to import pickle up here
so import pickle all right sweet okay so
pick a lot loads pick a lot dumps and
that is obviously instead of pause
player equals data we're gonna say
player players player equals data and
again same concept as before what's
going to happen is the what he called
the client is gonna send us a player
object we're gonna replace the existing
player object with that new player
object and then we're gonna send back
the other player objects like the other
clients okay so now what we're gonna do
is just change these pause to be player
or players like that okay
same thing here employers and then when
we send it back what we'll do is we will
just turn it into a object right so
we'll just do that pickle dog dumps and
send it back so say pickle dot dumps
reply like that and that should actually
be about it so let's go back or sorry
there's something we need to do in
client so now what we're gonna do is
essentially we've set up our network
class so that we're gonna be able to
send that object data we've set up the
server so we're gonna be able to receive
that object data we're gonna
by the objects we're storing in the list
here and then we're gonna send back the
other ones to the other client so in
clients all we have to do now is set up
player 1 and player 2 and then send that
data so really straightforward it's very
similar to before what we're gonna do
first of all just say p1 we're actually
just P is is equal to n dot get P ok
because in the network class remember
what we're doing is when we initially
connect so let's go back to server we're
just gonna send the initial player
object which is going to be whatever
player it is so 0 or 1 so let's just say
that this clients player object is gonna
be and get P okay and then we'll say
actually I think that's all we have to
do for yeah that is all we have to do
for that inside this while loop now what
we're gonna do is every frame we're
gonna send this player object which
we'll be updating with P dot move and
we'll just get the reply and say that
that's p2 so we're gonna do is when I
say p2 equals and then in this case
we'll just say P dot or not P and don't
send P and that's all we have to do and
notice here that we don't have to do
with all this like make what do you call
it make pause read pause all that stuff
and I believe this should be working if
I didn't make any mistakes let's cross
the fingers and let's try this out
waiting for connection let's go to
client one run that okay and client two
running that and now notice that these
rectangles are the same color and watch
what happens if I move this red one
see how it's red on the other screen as
well now that already shows us one of
the advantages of doing it this way is
that we can store information like color
as well not just position and if we want
to store maybe like there was a text
attribute on each of these players we
could store that as well if we wanted to
store more information in the player
like a health or something like that be
a lot easier to do that by just sending
the actual player object that has like
an unlimited amount of attributes rather
than just sending a little tupple that
has like five six or eight which is the
position so the reason I went through
the trouble of showing you the other way
is to show you the massive advantage of
doing it this way and just to give you
kind of perspective if you're making
something really simple and you don't
use any objects that's how you can do it
with string data but I think
this way is a lot easier and we've just
cleaned up quite a bit of code we've
gone rid of a bunch of functions and
moving forward this is going to make
things a lot easier for us
I'm pretty much gonna be gutting
everything we already did we'll keep a
little bit of it but we're just gonna
really add to a bunch of that and just
yeah we're gonna be gutting most of it
and we're actually gonna be working to
create online rock-paper-scissors
now I know this sounds a kind of a lame
game but let me show you because it's
actually pretty complex and if you can
understand how to make this game then
you're gonna be able to understand how
to make any other kind of online game
because the principles are the same in
terms of sending information waiting for
players to go and there's a lot of
different things and you might not think
about that we actually have to do to
code something like online
rock-paper-scissors okay so let's this
is client number one
I'm just running another PI game window
or PyCharm window with the server
running on it and you can see obviously
it's been oversized but it says waiting
for player okay so I'm gonna launch
another client and then excuse me you
can see when I launch that it loads both
of them up into the game and it says
your move opponents your move opponents
and currently it's waiting so I believe
this one's player two and this one's
player one so if I make a move here on
let's say rock it'll lock in my move and
says your move is rock and then over
here it says obviously the opponent's
move is locked in because it's like
looking for this guy's move and now if
he makes it move like let's say scissors
then it says you win you lost and then
it just resets and you can keep playing
games now I'm also gonna be adding more
to this this is just like the beta
version I'm gonna have wins ties and
losses keeping track and top hand corner
and when you load in you're gonna be
brought to a menu screen which will
allow you to like start a new game or to
leave or we'll add that later as we go
but this is the main functioning game
and you can see obviously it's working
well tie game and it restarts this also
allows for unlimited amount of clients
to play so for example if I launch
another two windows you can see these
guys now have their own game going it's
kind of difficult because I can't really
get four on the screen but anyways if I
go like scissors paper that works
independently of these games and these
games can kind of play at their own time
which is really interesting and really
cool and if you disconnect one of them
it automatically disconnects the pair
and that's just because obviously you
can't play against no one right so yeah
okay sweet so that's that let's start
getting
to the code okay so first thing we're
gonna do is we're actually gonna code a
game class okay and this is just gonna
be responsible for holding all the
information for our game that we need so
for example did player 1 go yet 2 player
to go yet what move did player 1 make
one move did player to make are both of
them connected to the server information
like that and you guys will see how much
information we actually need it's also
gonna store things like keeping track of
who won or who lost how many ties how
many wins since we're gonna do with this
game class so let's start making it so
class game I'm doing this in its own
file by the way just called game you are
gonna need the end zone file because
it's gonna have to be accessed by both
the client and the server okay we're
gonna define our initialization in here
we're gonna take ID and say self
thoughts p1 wedge equals false self dot
p2 went equals false and obviously you
guys know what this is gonna do it just
gonna stand for if player 1 has made a
move or not if player 2 is made a move
we're gonna do self dot ready equals
false if I could type that correctly
we're also gonna add self thought ID so
self that ID equals ID and this is just
gonna stand for the current games ID so
each game we create is gonna have its
own unique numeric ID so that we can
determine who is like what clients are a
part of what game and whatnot we're
gonna do self dot moves equals and then
we'll just do none and not in here
because currently the moves are none but
we'll just store two positions so we can
change that we'll say self thought wins
equals and then 0 0 obviously this one
is gonna stand for player 1 this one's
gonna stand for player 2
we'll say self thought tie is equals 0
that's all we need for the anit so next
one is gonna say get underscore player
underscore move now what this is gonna
do is exactly what it says is just gonna
get I don't know how I added that there
you're just gonna get the player move
that we asked for
so we're gonna take P which is going to
be either a 0 or 1 and we're gonna do is
simply return self dot moves and P and
just remind ourselves we'll say that P
is in the range of 0 and 1 so we're only
going to take value 0 or 1 and then
we're going
returned a moose a move here okay and
there's that's just to remind ourselves
that we have to pass here or one
obviously zero is going to represent
player one and one is gonna represent
player two okay next one
play so this one's a bit more
complicated not crazy we're going to
take play we're gonna take a player and
we're gonna take a move and what this is
gonna do is it's simply going to update
our moves list with that players move
pretty straightforward so what we're
gonna do here is we're just gonna say if
player equals equals zero then what
we'll do is we'll say self dot moves 0
equals move oh actually you know what
let's do this sorry I'm just looking at
my other screen right now we'll say self
dot moves player equals move but now
what we have to do is based on the
player we have to update if p1 went or
p2 went okay so what we'll do in here is
if it's player one obviously we'll do p1
went equals true I'm gonna need a self
before that and then we'll call we'll
just do a little else here because it's
not player 0 must be player 1 it will
say self thought Pichu want if I could
spell once equals trip so that will just
keep track of if we've gone or not
sweet next method this one's really easy
it's gonna be called connected and it's
just gonna tell us if the two players
are currently connected to the game if
they are it'll allow us to load in and
that's how we can determine whether we
should show waiting for player or not on
the screen right so we'll say return
self thought ready and that's just gonna
tell us obviously if we're ready and
that'll be updated from the server side
which we'll do later next method define
both went this is just simply gonna
return if both of our players went so to
do that we're just gonna say self
thought p1 once and why can I not spell
that word hand itself thought p2 went
like that okay next one is winner this
one is a bit more complicated but it's
just gonna keep track of where it's
actually gonna tell us who's won the
game so if we call this method we're
assuming that both players have gone
we're gonna check their moves excuse me
against one another and see if they want
so we're actually gonna have to check
nine possible cases because there's
three moves each player could do 3 times
3 9 so what we'll start by doing is what
I say p1 equals self dot moves 0 dot
upper and that's here the reason we're
doing this is because we just want to
get the first letter of the move because
the move is going to be stored as rock
paper or scissors the string and it's
just gonna be easier for us to type out
for example R or s or what do you call
it or P to check the moves as opposed to
having to check the entire word so we're
just going to get that first letter by
doing move 0 we're gonna upper it and
then we're gonna take that first leg
we're gonna do the exact same thing for
p2 except obviously we're going to need
oh I don't know what I did there we're
going to need moves one upper and now we
can start checking to see who's won so
we're going to stay to start winner is
equal to negative one now that's because
there could be no winner there could be
a tie so if it's tied we're gonna say
negative one if player one is the winner
it's gonna be 0 if player two is the
winner it's gonna be one okay so we're
gonna do is going to say if P 1 equals
equals R and P 2 equals equals Scissors
what we'll do is we'll say winner equals
zero because player 1 1 that will say L
if P 1 equals equals S and P 2 equals
equals R then we'll say winner equals 1
believe do another LF and I know this is
tedious but this is the way you have to
check for rock-paper-scissors I don't
think there's an easier way to do it if
you know an easier way let me know and P
2 equals equals R and if you guys don't
want to type this you can always copy
from my website check with Tim dotnet
okay so say winner equals paper beats
rock so beat winner equals 1 or 0 sorry
we'll say L if P 1 equals equals R and P
2 equals equals P then winner equals 1
and we've just got two last ones to
check here so we'll say L if P 1 equals
equals s and P 2 equals equals
our and then p2 is the winner so winner
equals one believe that's oh sorry I'm
gonna mess this up this should be P
thanks so P rock rock paper scissors
paper yeah
when R equals zero okay
LF p1 equals equals paper and p2 equals
equals scissors then winner equals one
and I believe that should be correct one
two three four five six okay sweet and
then the other cases are if it's a tie
so if none of this is the case then they
must have tied and then all we're gonna
do is simply return winner like that
okay and one very last method then we're
actually done with this class we can
move to something else is to find reset
went and all this is going to do is say
self-thought p1 went equals false and
self thought p2 went equals false pretty
straightforward and this is the game
class I know I kind of sped through this
but it's pretty trivial how this works
we just need to get this out of the way
so we can start coding some other stuff
okay sweet so we've done this class next
thing I think we want to work on is
network so network actually you guys are
gonna have to modify yours to look like
mine now get P and what do you call it
so this first half so an it and get P
are gonna be the same as what we had
previously the only thing this changes
is connect and this end so in connect
instead of what do you call it like
unpicking an object so like pickled alt
loads what we're simply doing is we're
gonna just connect to the client like we
did before
but instead of unpicking it we're just
gonna decode it I'm gonna say self dot
client receive 2048 decode would return
that value and that's because when we
initially connect to the server what
we're gonna get from the server is our
player number which means we're either
player 0 or reply 1 now that's important
because that's going to determine where
on the screen we're drawing certain
things and how we're sending information
back to the server and updating player 1
and player 2 right because technically
each player thinks that their player 1
but each one needs to be assigned either
a 0 or 1 by the computer so we know
where to store information right
okay so that's how we modify that just
do D code instead of pickling sending I
believe is the same except what we're
gonna do is instead of pickling an
object to send we're simply gonna send a
string and we're gonna load an object so
that means we're gonna send string data
to the server and we're gonna receive
back object data so when we receive
something we have to pickle that loads
it in but when we're sending it we just
have to encode the string okay so just
make sure it looks like this I don't
think I need to go through this we've
already done this for the past two three
videos and that's the network class so
game and network are done the next
things to do our server and client now
server and client are a bit more
complicated so inside of server I guess
we could do this first because it
doesn't really depend on the client to
work where the client kind of depends on
the server we're gonna change a bunch of
things so this is what it mine looks
like now I've kind of gutted the entire
threaded client I got rid of most of the
stuff like most of the other stuff I
just left this beginning thing so that
the server IP the port the socket
connecting listening waiting for
connection so by the way some of you
were saying you're having issues with FS
don't listen you can just make this zero
it doesn't really matter what's in here
and some of you were saying like you're
having issues just you can just delete
it and type it in again and apparently
that works that's what someone said so I
don't know don't ask me about that but
if you're writing it to issues do that
okay so what we're gonna do now is we
want to make it so you can have
unlimited connections at once
now that means we're gonna have to have
unlimited games running at the same time
so before what we were doing when we had
those players moving around the screen
so we were just wearing like player 1
player 2 and we just had a list that had
two entries that's how we were doing
that what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna have a list that contains a bunch
of different games and those games
actually you're sorry it's gonna be a
dictionary those games will be accessed
by their ID and you guys will see how
this works it's a bit complicated but
just follow along and yeah so I gotta
just open up my other file so don't make
any mistakes here ok so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna do connected equals
set we're gonna define some variables
we'll talk about these do games equals a
blank dictionary and
I D count equals zero so the reason
we're adding these is games this
dictionary is going to store our games
so it's gonna have an ID as a key and
the game as like a game object like this
okay as the value this connected is just
gonna store the IP addresses of the
connected clients we're starting to set
just so it's easier to access later I
don't actually know if we use this we
might but we'll see you okay
ID count obviously is just gonna keep
track of our current ID so that means
what game we should recreate so we don't
override games and say like two games
have the same ID because obviously we
can't have that happening okay so that's
fine for that we're not gonna deal with
anything threaded client right now we're
gonna go down to our while loop and this
is where we're gonna create new games
based on new people joining or possibly
delete games actually will delete games
from threaded client so we're gonna do
right now is when someone connects this
this runs right and we run a new so like
once we accept a connection everything
after this runs so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna say ID count plus equals
one if you notice me looking away I'm
just looking at my other screen to make
sure I don't make any mistakes on this
now what id count plus equals one is
gonna do obviously is it's gonna keep
track of how many people are connected
to the the server at once because
obviously right like once this happened
we can except then we go down the while
loop we start a new thread and then we
wait for another connection so we're
just gonna keep track of that what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say P equals
zero just standing for the current
player we're going to say game ID equals
and this is gonna be weird but just
follow along with me we could ID count
minus one integer division two now what
this is gonna do is essentially every
two people that connect to the server
we're gonna increment game ID by one and
what game ID is gonna be or every we'll
say it's yeah well add it by one what
game ID is gonna do is keep track of
what ID our game is gonna be so like for
example if we have ten people connected
to the server we're gonna have five
games right so that's what this line of
code is doing for us it's keeping track
of how many games or if we need to add a
new game because obviously if we have
like six people connected all of them
are gonna be playing each other a
seventh person connects
well it doesn't have a game too giant we
have to create a new game for it to join
hopefully that makes sense okay so what
we'll do next and say if I D count
modulus two equals equals one and what
this is gonna stand for is if you're
gonna be player one or player two and if
this happens is actually we need to
create a new game because this means
that we don't have a pair for our new
player so for example like say this
numbers three that means two people are
already playing so though it's one
person just connected so we need to
create a new game that's what this
modulus two is getting okay so to do
that we're gonna say games game ID
equals game game ID okay and I believe
this actually speak capital so obviously
start at the beginning of this I forgot
to mention I import a game so from game
import game that is important and yes
actually what we're doing is we're just
going to say that game ID which is that
key in our dictionary is now equal to a
new game so we can access that and add
players to it and whatnot sweet so that
works let's actually print out a message
here and just say creating a new game
dot dot just so that in our server we
get some kind of output and we can have
a look at that if something's going
wrong so otherwise if there we don't
need to create new game meaning we have
let's say three people are connected so
that second game already exists and
another person connects well that person
has to be a part of this new game so
what we're gonna do then is ringside
games game ID dot ready equals true now
what this means is that the second
player connected so there's two players
now connected to our game so now we can
say that that game is ready to start
playing because both the players are
connected so that means that they can
will obviously play against each other
right so that's what we'll do we'll set
that dot ready equal to true and
obviously we're storing all the games on
the server side as opposed to on the
client side and then we're going to say
is going to say P equals one and what
this means is player equals one and
you'll see why we need to do this in a
second ok so now we're going to do start
new thread
now notice insert new thread I added two
new
rameters pee and game ID so this means
the current player so it's either player
0 or player 1 and the game ID and game
ID is gonna stand for which game in this
games dictionary are we playing in this
threaded client like which one of our
clients that's connected here is playing
which game that's why we need that so
let's pass that information so we have
passed P which is either gonna be 0 or 1
like we have there and we're gonna pass
game ID and then we'll have that up here
and just remember that threaded clients
one of these functions is continuously
running for every single one of our
clients so if we have a hundred clients
we have a hundred different functions of
this running in the background at the
same time ok awesome so that's how about
it's working inside our threaded client
now excuse me I should take a break
there inside of our threaded client we
now need to add some things so the first
thing we're gonna add is ID count we're
gonna global ID count because if someone
leaves our game or disconnects we're
gonna need to subtract from that so we
can keep track up accordingly like how
many people are connected how many games
are running and all that stuff ok now
the first thing we're gonna do when
someone can next to our woody called our
server is we're gonna send them what
player there remember what I was saying
in this game class or in this network
class sorry then when we connect we're
initially just going to decode a string
that's either going to be 0 or 1 to tell
us what player we are ok so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna send conduct
send STR Dalton code Pete and I believe
this should be actually string P like
that so that we know if we're player to
0 or if we're player 1 that's the first
step
next we're gonna say reply equals a
blank string you want to say a while
true and this is where we're gonna start
doing some more serious stuff in here so
in the way that it's going to work in
terms of sending string data from our
client to our server is we're gonna send
one of three different options we're
gonna send get we're gonna send reset or
we are going to send a move and the move
is going to be like rock paper or
scissors
so if we send get what that means is we
want to get the game from the server so
we're gonna send that every frame we're
gonna send get a string yet and then the
server is gonna look and it's gonna say
okay what are you sending your sending
get alright we'll send you back the game
that's how that's gonna work
another option is reset reset means
reset the game the game has finished
both players played reset and that's
gonna be sent from the client side
because the client knows when we want to
reset right the last one is a move same
thing when the client makes a move so
like rock-paper-scissors if they are a
little out to make that move which will
check on the client side we'll send that
move to the server the server will
update the game accordingly and then it
will send back the game to the client
and that's how that's going to work
sweet so what we'll do now is going to
say well true let's say data equals con
dot receive and then we're gonna say
4096 and here instead of 2048 which
you're using before dot decode the
reason we're doing this is just in case
we're sending too much information that
is more than 2048 bits we want to just
double this number so we can get more if
you run into any issues that say like
pickle data was true onst or like ran
outta input just increase this number
okay you can literally just do x 2 in
here and that should hopefully fix the
error if it doesn't work you can like x
4 x 8 and that should hopefully fix your
error for you okay so now what we're
going to say is gonna say if game ID in
games now
I'll talk about why we're doing this in
a second we're gonna sit there and say
game equals games game ID so essentially
every time we run this while loop we're
gonna check if the game still exists and
that's what we're doing right so in this
games dictionary we're seeing if this
game ID which is the key to access the
game is still there now why would we
check that well if one of our clients
disconnects from the game we're actually
gonna delete that game from the what do
you call it the games thing now what
that's doing for us excuse me is not
only like keeping track of our memory
which means that we're not gonna
continue Li keep creating games so like
Sarah server ran for weeks and we never
deleted any games then we probably
rotten run out of memory on our computer
right if we're playing a lot of games
but it's also gonna tell the other
client that was connected to that game
that hey this game no longer exists that
means the other person must have
disconnected from it so we have to do
something accordingly and go back to the
menu screen right do something like that
okay so that's we'll do there and then
we're going to say in here is gonna say
if not data we're gonna break this
similar to before so I'll go through it
a bit quicker we're gonna say else and
now we're going to check the three
different things that could have been
sent right so we've received the data so
we're gonna check if we got reset get or
if we got a move so the first thing
we'll check will save data equals equals
reset okay then we're gonna say if data
does not equal yet
and then else sorry this should be an
Elif Alec data it does not equal get
else we'll do something else actually do
we need an else no we don't you know
okay so if data equals reset what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say game dot
reset right because we already have the
game and if we look in here what resets
doing is essentially it's resetting both
players one so we can play another game
really straightforward for that next one
if data equals yet what we're gonna do
is say game or if that it does not equal
get sorry so if it didn't equal reset
and it does not equal get well then it
must be a move so it means we're either
getting rock paper or scissors so we're
gonna send that move to the game to
update it so to do that we're gonna say
game don't play and then we're going to
do with the current player number which
is P and then the move and the move is
gonna be
whatever this data is right so it'll be
data okay and then otherwise so I guess
after that um what should we do here
we'll say reply equals game and that
what we ready to do is going to be gone
dot send all I'm going to say pickle dot
dumps and not data sir reply okay and
what this is gonna do let me just make
sure I didn't rent any errors here is
simply going to
package up our game into that nice sin
double form we're gonna send it over to
our clients clients gonna receive it on
picolit and then use it to obviously
make moves and do different things and
draw it to the screen and all that okay
alright so I think that makes sense we
can go through it really quickly what
time we got 25 minutes all right so
we'll go through really quickly
essentially what's happening when you
connect we're gonna check if we have an
even amount of players or an odd amount
of players if it's an odd amount of
players when you connect that means we
need to create a new game so we create a
new game if it's not that means we need
to assign you to a game so what we're
gonna do is make the current game that
only has one player in it ready we're
gonna assign you to that and start a new
thread when we start the new thread
what's gonna happen is we're gonna send
to the client what player they are
either player zero or player one and
then what we're gonna do is we're going
to constantly receive string data from
the client if the game still exists then
what we'll do is we'll check if they're
sending us reset get or remove they're
sending us a move we'll make that move
they're sending us reset we'll apply
that reset to the game and then we're
just gonna constantly send back to them
the game object and now what we need to
do is just really quickly add some else
statements in here so that if some of
this stuff doesn't happen we have like a
catch for it okay so what we'll do here
is we're just gonna simply say else
break okay that should be lined up here
and we're just gonna add a try and
except up here so we're gonna say try
and we're going to indent all this by
just highlighting and pressing tab let's
say accept and then pass I think that's
yeah no not pass er accept and then
break just in case you know something
goes wrong with this data dot receive we
want to make sure the server keeps
running so we have that try and accept
and then underneath this accept in line
with the main function indentation what
we'll do is if we break it out of this
while loop we need to close the game and
delete it so to do that is actually
we're gonna print some on my wrong file
here we're going to print lost
connection and then we're gonna print
what do you call it
closing game okay actually we can print
that game ID too if we won't see what
game idea we're closing so said lost
connection closing game game ID okay and
then we're gonna try to delete games
game ID otherwise we will accept and
pass okay and then underneath here last
thing we're gonna do is gonna say ID
count - equals 1 and we're going to say
connection got close now that I actually
think about it we should probably put
this closing game only in this try after
we delete just so that we don't we only
close the game once we don't say we're
closing the game twice ok so what we're
doing down here essentially is if we
break out of this while loop so for
example if the game no longer exists
we're gonna break if something goes
wrong with this getting data so like the
player disconnected we're gonna break
we're gonna say lost connection we're
gonna try to delete that game the reason
we have this try here is because if both
players disconnect at the same time one
player will delete the game before the
other so if we try to delete a key that
doesn't exist we're gonna run into an
issue so we try that if that works we
will say print closing game and then
we'll say that game ID otherwise we're
gonna pass we're going to subtract from
the ID count and we're gonna close the
connection sweet so we're rolling we're
going pretty fast here now all we got to
do is code the client now this is
probably the most amount of code I think
it's about a hundred lines it just is a
lot of drawing stuff okay so I'm in take
a break we'll be back in one second and
we're gonna code the client all right so
I'm back now and we've got about 150
lines to write for this file it's pretty
tedious because a lot of the stuff is to
do with the drawing like we need those
buttons to be working
we need like all that text to be showing
up so that's like 90% or not 90% but
like 70% of the code about to write is
just gonna be cosmetic stuff but I mean
what do you want to tell you that's what
we need to do if we're gonna make an
online graphical game right so let's
start by just coding a class and this is
gonna be our button class just that when
we have those three buttons you know it
just makes things easier so we're gonna
do our own it when we need to be an itch
I'm gonna go for text
sorry I'm coding in the wrong file text
XY and color and we're just gonna say
that the width and the height will be
uniform in here and we'll just make it
the same for all of our buttons we're
gonna say self-thought tax equals text
self-taught x equals x sellout y equals
y and self the color equals color okay
sweet we also add a width and a height
here so we'll say self dot width equals
150 self-thought height equals 100 and
feel free to play with these numbers
it's just what I decided by the way guys
just really want to say this I'm not
focusing on how good this game looks I
know it looks like crap but you guys I
know can go through and tweak the colors
and tweak the positions and all that I
just don't want to focus on that because
I want to get the hard stuff out of the
way in the tutorial okay so let's do a
little draw method in here
pretty straightforward there's a new
play game dot draw dot rect and then for
the rectangle we're going to take window
which is that parameter for the draw and
then we're gonna do what should we do
cover herself docked self thought color
and we're gonna do that rectangle
position which is gonna be self dot X
self dot y self dot width and self
thought height like that okay and then I
guess let's see if there's anything else
we need to add to that no that's fine
we're going to find a font so we
actually need to make sure you just add
this at the top pygame font got a net
okay make sure you guys add that and
we're gonna do font equals high game
dark thoughts dot s sys font should help
every spell font correctly and then here
you're gonna pick your favorite fonts
I like Comic Sans I'm gonna make this
how big should this be let's make it 40
and then what we're gonna do is going to
render some font so we're gonna say text
equals font render and we're gonna put
self dot text we're gonna do one and
we're gonna do the color which will be I
guess in this case black or white 255
255 255 okay next we're gonna draw this
on the screen now we want this to be
centered on the button so I'm gonna do
some like decently complicated math it's
not really that
but we're gonna say wind-up blip text
and then we're gonna say self-thought X
- is it - no it's + self-thought X + in
brackets and we're gonna round in these
brackets I know this is confusing or
into yourself though with over 2 - round
I'm going to say text get underscore
width / 2 now what this is doing
essentially is we're starting out our
exposition but obviously we want our
text to be centered so to send our text
we need to know not only the width of
the like container of the button but the
width of our text so we're gonna get the
width of our text our VAR button we're
gonna subtract that from the width of
woody coats our text so that way it
should add like 20 or 30 pixels from the
left side so our Texas Center okay for
the Y we'll do a similar thing so inside
make sure you don't mess up these
brackets inside here we're just gonna
actually copy this and we're gonna paste
it right after a comma and we're simply
gonna say self dot y + round self dot
height okay + TxDOT get underscore
heights or - text up Gunners gonna write
/ - and that should Center our button
yeah okay next we're gonna say define
click we're gonna add a position here
this is just gonna tell us if we clicked
on the button or not so it's a really
basic if statement yes we're just going
to say X 1 equals pause 0 + y 1 equals
paused 1 now what we're gonna say is
gonna say if self thought X is less than
or equal to X 1 less than or equal to
self dot X + self Bell width and self
dot Y is less than or equal to Y 1 less
than or equal to self dot y + self dot
height believe that's correct
let me just check this yep that's
correct then what we'll simply do is
we'll return true indicating that we did
press the button otherwise we will
return false now I know I'm speeding
through this but it just because
really basic pygame stuff and we're
doing online games so make sure I change
that so don't want to focus too much on
the cosmetics but essentially what this
is doing is it's checking if the
coordinate which we're gonna pass in
here which is gonna be at up of x and y
of our mouse position is actually in the
button and the way we're doing that is
we're saying well we go on the X right
we check if it's greater than the X we
check if it's less than the X plus the
width so like if it's in between the
little box and then for the Y value we
do the same thing but we're checking
vertically to see if it's in that box if
you don't understand that I have PI game
tutorials where I go through like
collision and how all that works I'm not
really going to talk about that right
now okay sweet so we've got that working
now what we're gonna do is actually
let's see what I want to code now let's
code the main function and that will get
them to redraw window so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to find
those three buttons so we're gonna have
at the bottom of our screen so
rock-paper-scissors do that we're gonna
say buttons equals and we're just gonna
make three buttons first button will be
rock it's going to say rock we're gonna
start it at 5500 and then we're just
gonna go and give it a color of zero
zero zero okay we're gonna create
another button will say button and then
we'll say scissors we'll give it a let
me just check here 250 as next 250 is
next 500 as a Y and for the color for
that I gotta check what color I made
this I believe that I made that ah
right okay so the two 5500 and then one
more button can anyone guess what this
one is gonna be it's gonna be paper
we're gonna put this out of position of
450 so I can go here 450 500 and we will
simply make it blue or green sorry 0 255
0 so red green blue okay sweet so that
should be it for our buttons and now
we'll get into the main function and
start coding some stuff the first thing
we're gonna need to do so you need to
say run is equal to false or
good to true I always do that we're
gonna say clock equals PI game time
clock
capital C hereby bad okay next we're
gonna say N equals Network right because
we're importing Network up here we're
gonna do a very similar thing to what we
did before and all the previous
tutorials where we just connect
initially by doing that initialization
and then we're gonna say P equals
actually player equals and dot get P
right and you should already have that
method
it's just returning that like connect
what we connected to right so when we
connect we get the player number which
is either 0 or 1 so we need that now it
reminds me it's gonna be a number so we
got to put int around this so that we
can compare it with other integers ok
and last we're gonna just print just so
we have this you are player player
now this just indicates to us like when
we initially run if we know we're zero
or 1 just to make sure everything's
working fine now we're gonna make a
while loop we're going to say it's not
main game loop we're gonna say well run
and then in here we're gonna do clock
dot tick 60 very similar to what we've
done before guys I'm gonna start adding
some new stuff in a second ok so now
that we've done this it's time to start
actually connecting and asking the
server for information so what we should
be doing here is every frame we should
be asking the server to send us the game
especially at the beginning of this loop
because right now we haven't actually
created a game class right we need to
get that from the server so we're
connected now we know what player we are
so now what we can do is we can try to
get that from the server so to do that
we're going to say game equals n dot
send get and that's literally as easy it
as it is we're doing except and then
we'll just what he call it will say run
equals false and we'll say print
couldn't get game ok and the reason
we're doing this and we're gonna break
as well is because when we if we send
this and we don't get a response from
the server that means the game doesn't
exist and what what if
that happens well then what we should do
is we should exit out of this game we
should print saying we couldn't get the
game and then we should try to reconnect
or start a new game with someone else so
this main function is gonna be like the
actual game running but once we exited
this main function we're gonna go to a
main menu and the main menu will allow
us to choose like who we want to play
against and a bunch of other stuff as
well okay you guys will see that later
okay so that's how we do that next what
we're gonna do is we're going to say if
game dot both went now what we're gonna
do here is if both players went well
we're not waiting for anything now we
need to see which one won so what we're
gonna do here is going to check which
player one and we're gonna display that
message accordingly on the screen so
what we're gonna do initially is we're
gonna redraw the window the reason we do
this right away is because we want to
make sure that if both players went
we're updating the window and on the
window it'll check like if both players
have gone like in this redraw window and
it'll draw the player moves for us so
you guys will see how that works in a
second we're gonna do a delay when a pie
game time delay 200 and now what we're
gonna do is we're going to try game
sorry game equals Adam don't send reset
now why we're doing this obviously is
because well if both players went we
need to tell the server to reset those
player moves right so inside a game if
we call reset went we're just gonna
reset it so that we were able to play
the next round after okay we're gonna
except except of course I can't spell
that we're gonna say Ryan
equals false we're gonna do the same
thing as before we're gonna print
couldn't get game couldn't get game and
then we're gonna break okay
now under this so after we send that
reset now what we want to do is we want
to display a message on the screen
indicating whether player one one or
player two one or like if you want or if
the other player one so the way we're
gonna do this and it's actually a decent
amount of lines is because we have to
like render font and then we got to
determine where we're gonna draw the
font and what's gonna be on the font so
we're first good just gonna
by defining thoughts will say font
equals PI game dot font dot sys font
okay in here we'll say comic sans font
size let's go to 94 this one now we're
gonna say if game dot winner and
remember if we go to game winner is
going to respond to us with either a 0 a
1 or a negative 1 so it would you have
to check if winner is 1 and player so
whenever our current player is 1 then
we're going to set you one if winner is
1 but the current player is 0 we're
gonna set you lost right so that's how
we can check this so to do that we're
gonna say if game note winner equals
equals 1 and player equals equals 1 and
remember we got that player from the
server so we know if we're either player
0 or player 1 on the client side and is
actually is do I need an ant oh sorry
or let's we need to do or game dot
winner
equals equals 0 and player equals equals
0 so essentially what we're gonna do
here is we're going to check if this
player won so we know what player we are
and we know what player 1 so if that
coincide like what player we are and the
player that one then will print out and
we'll say or we'll put on the screen you
want right telling that client they want
so we'll say text equals font render and
then here we simply say u 1 exclamation
point and then we can just do one and
then a color and obviously color we just
you like red like that ok on the screen
okay so else actually L if and now we're
gonna check if they lost washi I think
we could do this easier we're gonna say
L if game winner equals equals negative
1 so if it if we tied what we'll do here
is we'll say text equals font dot render
and we'll just say tie game exclamation
point
1 again we'll put that in red ok
and now else so if we didn't win and we
didn't tie we must have lost so we can
literally just copy this and we'll just
say you lost as the
next okay so you lost dr. sweet and now
what we're gonna do is just render that
font put it on the screen so our not
render it just put on the screen so say
wind blitt text and now we're gonna do
the exact same thing that we did before
to get it in the middle of the screen
and just be a little bit easier so we're
just gonna say I believe to a needler
brackets no I don't think so we'll say
width over two and that's the width of
the actual screen - text get underscore
width we need those brackets over - I'm
gonna do comma and now we'll just do the
same thing with height so say height
over two - text dot get underscore
Heights over - okay so that's gonna put
it in the middle screen we're gonna
update the display eye game display
update and we're going to delay so
pygame dot time dog delay and I'm gonna
put two thousand for two seconds you
guys can put whatever you want in here
okay so let's break this down really
quickly if both players went that means
now we're gonna check who won so we're
going to do is we're going to redraw the
window we're going to what do you call
it apply a small delay of 0.2 seconds
just so that we can see what both
players did before it immediately pops
up who wanted who lost so actually let's
make this a lay half a second we're
gonna send to a server
reset so we're gonna reset both players
went so the next time that we start
playing we can both players are allowed
to move we're gonna say Ron equals false
if this doesn't happen if this doesn't
work we're gonna prank couldn't get a
game we're gonna break now otherwise so
like if this worked we sent the game
we're gonna create a font we're going to
check who won so either we won we tied
it we lost when display that to the
screen
we're in delay for two seconds and then
we're gonna play the game again after
okay awesome so we're almost done I'm
just gonna add this pretty actually
complex for loop in here serene do now
is gonna say for event in PI game event
dot gets very standard for Poggi
probably seen this before
I'm gonna say if event dot type equals
equals PI game dot quits
then what we're gonna do is gonna say
run it was false and we're gonna say
pygame dog quit so this just means that
they hid the whole X button at the top
of the corner now we're gonna check if
they actually press their mouse button
down so this is how we're gonna check if
they pressed a button this what we're
gonna do now it's a if event dot type
equals equals PI game dot mouse button
down then we will do is we'll get the
mouse position to do that range say if
we're gonna say PI game you've got pause
hi I'm dawn Mouse doc get underscored
pause so what we're doing here is we're
checking if they press right middle or
left mouse button if they do let's get
the mouse position now for every single
button we're gonna check if we click
that button if we did we're gonna do
something accordingly okay so we're
going to do now I'm gonna say for button
in BTN s remember we define buttons up
here then what we're gonna say is if BTN
dot click pause now if they did click
the position there's a few things we
need to check oh and else when you check
this sir and game DUP connected sorry so
what this game duck connected is doing
is just making sure that it's not gonna
let us press like rock-paper-scissors
unless we both players are on so that's
just so that we don't run into an issue
where we can make a move before the
other player connects okay so just add
this and game enough connected what
we'll do now is we're gonna check what
our current player is because this is
gonna determine how we send a move so
we're gonna do now is gonna say if
player equals equals zero if not game
dot what do you call it p1 went then
we'll do something otherwise so we'll
just put else here and we'll check if
not p2 game vt1 okay so what we're doing
now and I haven't coded the rest of it
yet is we're just gonna check if we
press one of the buttons so remember we
have that click method in our button
that tells us if we clicked on it so if
we do click on it and we're connected to
the game what
when a check of our current player is
zero or one now what we're doing is if
we're player zero well we're gonna check
if player zero has gone yet if they've
gone obviously we're not gonna let them
make a move right because they've
already made that move they can't change
their move once they made it
same thing with player two so if we're
not player zero we're player one clearly
that means we're gonna check if player
two is gone yet and if they haven't gone
we'll allow them to move okay so what
we'll do in here now is we're gonna make
a move now to make a move remember we
just need to send to the network our
move so we're just gonna say n dot sent
or to the server sorry and all we're
gonna do is we're just gonna send the
text of the button now the text of the
button will be a rock paper or scissors
right and that's it precisely the move
that we're gonna make depending on what
button we're clicking so it's a really
nice dynamic way to do that now once
we've done that right so if we go to
server what happens here is if we send
that we're gonna play that move and
we're gonna update it on the game so
that the other client when it gets that
game board again we'll have the update
move you guys we'll see how this works
in a second okay so that's working well
now all we need to do is just add in
line with this right here we're gonna
say redraw window we're gonna give it
win we're gonna give it what else do I
need to give it game and P which stands
for a current player and that's actually
it for and make sure you just call are
calling main down here at the end of
climb that's actually it for this main
function so now all we need to do is do
redraw window and we're really close to
done so we got another like twenty lines
and then once we do that we're actually
finish this game and then we can start
testing it out and talking about some
more things we can add to it okay so
what we're gonna do now is yeah it's
actually quite a bit of work is we're
gonna draw all the stuff on the screen
now so we've done all the logic aspect
of it down here in this main function
now we need to draw everything so it's
more tedious and is difficult but we're
just gonna first start by checking if
not game dot connected now this just
means if we have not yet had the other
player connect then all we're gonna do
is we're just gonna print on the screen
waiting for player and we're not going
to show anything else so to do that or
instead font equals PI game dot font
sys font
obviously is Comic Sans and then the how
big should be let's make it eat okay and
then we're gonna say text equals font
dot render in here we're gonna say
waiting for Claire dot dot dot one color
let's do a nice red and let's actually
add true here for bold okay
okay so we're gonna blit this on the
screen so to do this we'll say wind dot
Blitz and we're gonna do again that same
I know a tedious thing to get in the
middle of the screen so we're just gonna
say with over to minus text get
underscore width and then we're gonna
say height over to minus text get
underscore height and actually we need
to make sure we're dividing both the
width and the height by two so let's do
that okay that's it for that
now else so this means if we actually
are connected both players are in now
it's time to start drawing the real
stuff on the screen so we need to draw
that what was it so actually let me pop
up client for you guys he can see what
it looks like it's running server rotten
client client great so if we want to see
the client what we do is we need to draw
this this this this and then the three
buttons okay so we're gonna have to do
these four texts and the thing is these
texts need to change on like they're
gonna be different depending on what
player is looking at it right so for
example here it's showing us what our
move is but notice it just says locked
in for opponents it doesn't tell us what
our move is and with the other players
move is right so we need to do that as
well okay so to do that let's start
we're gonna make another font a font
equals pie game don't font dot sys font
Comic Sans size of this font let's make
it sixty and then what we're going to do
is I say text equals
font dot render and we're gonna do your
move so we're gonna start by just doing
your move and like opponent move because
those aren't gonna change they're gonna
stay the same no matter what and for
that we're gonna do one and the color I
had there was going
sian I think right so we'll do this to
feel free to change the color I know it
probably isn't look the best and let's
just split this at a static position on
the screen so say text and let's go
8,200 okay alright next so actually
still in this else statement we're gonna
copy this I'm just sorry what am i doing
just this text and this wind part and
we're gonna put it down here and say you
were move we're gonna say opponent move
is that you spell that let's change that
to opponents and actually let's just get
rid of moves me too big opponents and
same color except we're just gonna
change the x value so that we draw it at
what you call it 380 like that okay so
that's it for your movement opponents
next what we need to do is bit more
complicated because now we have to draw
what the actual moves are so remember
we're obviously we don't want to show
the other player what one of the players
moves is unless both of them have gone
it's like we want to know what our move
is but we can't know what the other
players move us until we've both made a
move so to do this what we're gonna do
we're going to start by just getting
both player moves bring us a game don't
get underscored player I just want more
we're gonna get move zero and we'll
actually will copy this and just do move
two and change this to one so we'll
start by getting the moves and then now
we're gonna check if we should show
those moves if we should show waiting or
if we should show locked in okay so to
do this we're gonna say if game dot both
went okay like that we're gonna say is
gonna say x1 equals font render and
we're just gonna use the same font as
before and what its gonna be is move 1
comma 1 comma and we'll make this black
so 0 0 okay and we'll copy this and
we'll do the same thing except text 2 is
gonna be equal to move to so essentially
this is saying if both of the players
have gone well we can show their moves
cuz they both made them so let's do that
and it's just rendering that font and
will display the font after you say that
works so now otherwise if both players
have not gone what we need to do
we need to actually let me just check
something for a second is we need to
determine if we're gonna show locked in
meaning the other player actually has
gone but we're not gonna show their move
or if we're gonna show waiting which
means the other player hasn't gone so to
do this we're gonna say if game dot p1
went and P equals equals zero so this is
saying if we have gone and it's our
current like we are the player we're
player 1 so if player 1 is gone and we
are player 1 what we're gonna do is
going to say X 1 equals font dot render
move 1 which is the move we've done
which is fine if we see that and then
we're gonna say 1 and color 0 0 0 ok L
if game dot p2 went and is this one it
is actually sorry game dot p1 went you
guys will see how this works in a second
what we're gonna say I'm gonna say text
2 equals the same thing now this might
be confusing but essentially what this
is doing is it's saying if player 1 is
gone and we are player 1 we're gonna say
if I spelled render correctly render
like that render sorry I got interrupted
there okay so if player 1 is gone and we
are player 1 then we want to show
underneath like you were move what our
move is otherwise what we want to show
is we want to show that like locked in
so we're gonna change this to locked in
underneath opponents move because it
means player 1 went but it's not us so
it's not our move so that means we want
to show it under opponents moves you'll
see how this works we're gonna say locks
in like that okay all right now we're
just gonna do else so this actually just
stands for if game dot p1 hasn't like if
they haven't moved yet we're just going
to say text 2 equals waiting so we say
waiting dub dub dub I believe that's
correct
um actually sorry these all need to be
text 1 my man okay all right I know this
is confusing but we'll go through
adapter all right so we're gonna
actually copy this and we're just gonna
change everything to 2 so this is gonna
be p2 this is gonna be 1 this is gonna
be - it's gonna be - and it's gonna be 2
and this is gonna be 2 as well and then
we just make sure that I did that
correctly I believe I did ok sweet and
now we are going to actually show these
we're gonna let these on the screen
we're actually really close to finish
guys so to do this we're gonna say if P
equals equals 1 so a for player 1 what
we'll do is say wind up lit and we'll
say text 2 and then we're gonna show it
we're gonna show it at a hundred and 350
okay now we'll copy this so ctrl D and
we'll blit 1 except instead about 100
we're gonna change this to 400 now we're
just gonna put an else so if we're not
player 1 clearly we must be player 0 so
we're just gonna reverse these player 1
player 2 now the reason we're doing this
is because this is gonna be where like
player 1 and player two's moves are
shown on the screen so we want it to
make so that for each of our clients
rather than saying like player 1 player
2 and having one of the clients have
their move on the right side and one of
them Abbott on the left side we want it
to be the same for each client you guys
will see how this works when we actually
run the thing
so let's actually just let's add in
drawing the buttons so to draw the
buttons we could we could draw them in
this else statement actually that might
be better yeah let's do it inside of
this this else okay we're gonna say for
BTN in buttons we're just gonna say BTN
draw and give it a win and I think
that's actually all we need to do and
lastly we're gonna update the display so
try game dot display update now assuming
I didn't make any critical errors this
should actually be working so I know
this has been a lot of code and a lot of
writing but I think I've kept it to just
about an hour now actually and that's
actually a pretty decent time for
creating a game like this so you guys
will see how this works out
okay so let's try running our server and
see if we got any errors first of all
okay server waiting for a connection
server started good sign so far
okay clients let's try running a client
so I'm going to client
Oh name P is not defined when game P ah
okay so what we're gonna do for client
this is a really easy fix just change
this to player and I might have to
change oh yeah
up here when I do redraw a game window
as well we gotta do win game and player
okay so fix that
alright client run waiting for player
alright good sign it's not another one
and what do you look at that okay they
both launched in now so you saw that
waiting for player showed up but as soon
as we are ready now both of them are
showing up okay so this should be player
1 this should be player 0 or player
player 1 player 2 right okay so let's
try this now Rock ran out of input self
client I receive 2048 okay so let just
have a quick look at why this might be
ah so I think I might've fine
found the issue I'm actually I don't
know if this is the issue exactly but we
do need to fix this where I do game dot
reset inside of server here it actually
must be reset went because that's what I
called it inside here reset went so just
gotta make sure we do that okay guys so
really silly error here actually um the
issue was on the server side here I'm
calling play right like game dot play
and so if I need to get rid of six I was
just printing out the exception so I can
see what it was but essentially play
doesn't actually exist because I
misspelled something on game I miss
spelt it i misspelled the player should
be play so that was the issue I was
running into it just it was very
difficult to see because it was just
accepting it and not like not printing
anything out just continuing to run the
server so I couldn't find it but
essentially if we run the server and run
the two clients now we should have
everything working I haven't actually
tested it so let's pray if I go paper
sweet so we goes paper here we're not
getting locked in over here so that
might be an issue but let's see if we
make something here then offense you
lost and you won okay so we have a
slight issue but it's pretty easy fix
let's just go up to client just look
through we're just probably messing
something up in the drawing code here so
oh that would make sense well we're not
actually end up drawing yeah so this if
P equals equals one this just needs to
top back one one indentation level
and now we should have everything
actually working fine so let's try this
now
client client and let's go rock ok so
that works but it's not doing the locked
in for some reason so let's check this
this locked in portion I just closed
that server and make sure that this is
actually working so that needs to be p2
went and well if this one should be
working those what's confusing okay so
actually so that one just need to be p2
went game p2 went let's try this server
and let's go client and let's run it
again and scissors locked in sweet so
that's actually working and the game is
pretty well finished all we got to do is
out a menu screen and we're gonna be
done so now let's go scissors this is a
scissors scissors that's not correct we
got to fix that as well okay I thought I
had everything working guys I really
thought so okay so I actually I did I
dunno the issue it was it's pretty
straightforward so in main here when we
check the let's see here the winners
where do we check winners if it equals
equals 1 because equals negative 1
ah ok so game don't winner needs
brackets of course it does so we need to
add that so obviously just some silly
Ares guys so server's running right now
let's run these clients see if
everything is indeed working as as it's
supposed to be now okay so let's try
this paper blocked in scissors you lost
you won yay okay everything's working
okay paper paper
tie game sweet okay so you guys can all
really mess around at the timing you can
see how this is working so the only last
thing to do now is watch this if I
disconnect disconnect both of them so
what we're gonna want to do now if that
happens is instead of just completely
like exiting the game we're gonna want
to bring them to a menu screen where
they can just click to reconnect and
this is a really this actually really
easy to do so what we're gonna do is
we're going to define another function
I'm gonna call this menu underscore
screen okay and in here all we're gonna
do is have a really basic while loop
that just checks if you click something
and all it's gonna do there
click the run that main function so
we're gonna do is just a run equals true
let's say well run okay and then in here
and say for event in PI game the event
dot gets and that obviously we're gonna
check if they click exit so if event
type because equals PI game of dot quit
then we will do is just do PI game don't
quit
Ron equals false otherwise if they click
any key so let's say if event dot type
equals equals PI game dot and we'll just
say mouse button down so I should just
get it they'll click the mouse button
then what we'll do is we'll simply say
Ron equals false and at the bottom of
Ron equals false so what we're going to
do is we're just gonna call main so all
this is gonna do and we'll call menu
underscore screen here so say well true
comma menu screen okay I'll go through
this in a second or say well true menu
screen okay so we're gonna do is in menu
screen if they click something we're
gonna can call the main function which
is simply going to what do you call it
do all of this stuff in here and then if
they exit out of the main function so if
you say like Ron equals false because
they disconnected it'll just rerun the
menu screen which means that they'll be
prompted to reconnect to new game
awesome what we'll do in here is what a
clock as well so say Clark equals PI
game dot time clock give it a tick so
clock dot tick sixty will do will just
draw something in here we don't need to
use the redraw window function we'll
just do font equals PI game dot font dot
sys font in here we'll go Comic Sans
we'll go sixty and then we're just gonna
render some text we'll say text equals
volunteer and ER in here will simply say
click to connect our click to play
exclamation point one some nice red text
and we can just continually actually we
can just window fill so wind up fill and
we'll just fill it with whites as your
zero or what I say gray actually 128 128
and we should just where is wind do I
define it up here somewhere yes I do so
that's sweet winds up there so what we
can do is just fill the window run into
this while loop put some text on the
screen we may actually have to fill this
every frame let's get rid of one of
those brackets I created so let's fill
this every frame actually okay so we'll
fill it we will blit this font so it's a
wind blitz text and you know what for
right now I don't want to deal we'll
just do it statically I'll just do like
150 so it's night at the top of the
screen actually let's go one hundred two
hundred okay and go I came don't display
don't update like that then if they
click something what should happen is
that you break this loop they should be
brought to the main thing and yeah that
should hopefully be working for us so
let's try this client click to play okay
a little a little sketchy on the click
to play but let's see you if we click to
play ok waiting for player so this is
what actually what I wanted so it says
waiting for player we're gonna wait for
someone else to connect
ok boom connected sweet so now we're
ready so let's just run a game let's go
rock scissors now let's just see what
happens if we click X this one goes to
the menu screen where it says click to
play and it can be woody called play
against someone else right and that's
exactly what we wanted we may also want
to add like a back button to go back but
I'll leave that to you guys so guys I'm
gonna leave the tutorial here if you
guys have any questions or run into any
bugs or anything please let me know this
is by no means like a full complete game
there's still obviously a lot of things
that could be added to this and I might
continue a serious later but I think for
now that's probably enough I hope that
you guys learned how to make an online
game I find this stuff really freaking
cool and really interesting how you can
have like a ton of different clients
from connecting together and that being
said I'll see you guys in another video